ATTENDING THE FIRST. HISTORICAL
A NATIVE AMERICAN SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS. WE HAVE OUR SOME OF
OUR SELECT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE MAKING THEIR WAY HERE IS
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES DIFFERENT
PRESS CONFERENCES ARE GOING ON
BUT WE HAVE WITH US ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD GLORIA. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. JOSE MEDINA IN ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WENDY CARILLO. NOT SURE
OF ANY MEMBER WANTED TO. GIVE
ANY REMARKS AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU. IT SAYS THINGS MOVE
ON YOU SEE MEMBERS COME IN AND
OUT AS- THINGS MOVE FORWARD IN
THE PANDA SKETCHES ARE GOING ON
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT.
HAPPEN IN THE CAPITAL WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL PRESS CONFERENCES
AND DIFFERENT COMMITTEES THAT.
ROLE INVOLVED ON. BUT WE DO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHERE WE JUST
CAME FROM THE PRESS CONFERENCE
ON THE TEN MILLION DOLLAR
TRAVEL DIVERSION PROGRAM AND
THE GRANTS THAT ARE THERE IN
TODAY THE ROLE OF ORDER WILL BE
WILL HAVE A PRESENTATION. ON
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICANHERITAGE COMMISSION THAT WILL
TAKE PLACE. AFTER THAT. WE'LL
HAVE. A PANEL ON ISSUES
IMPACTING CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES. IS
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING THE
EPIDEMIC OF MISSING AND
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
AND GIRLS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION. AND
THEY WILL HAVE ANOTHER
COMPONENT TALKING ABOUT THE
TRIBAL DIVERSION PROGRAMS THERE
ARE SOME MUCH NEEDED. IN INDIAN
COUNTRY. AT THIS TIME WE WANT
TO BRING UP OUR FIRST PANEL
WHICH WILL BE MISSED DEBBIE
TREADWELL AND MISS CRISTINA
SNYDER GIVING US OVERVIEW OF
THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. AND AT THE END OF
ALL THE DISCUSSION WILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END.
THANK YOU I HAVE A MISS TRIED
WELL DID YOU WERE YOU GOING
FIRST. ALL RIGHT. MY NAME IS
DEBBIE TRACK WAY I AM WITH THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE. GOING
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A FREE. A
HISTORY OF NATIVE AMERICANS. IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES IT WAS
BECOMING MORE APPARENT WITH THE
INCREASING NUMBER OF LAND
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THAT ROOM
CROUCHING UPON ARCHAEOLOGICAL
SITES IN PLACES A SPECIAL
SIGNIFICANCE TO NATIVE
AMERICANS. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE A GROUP OF NATIVE
AMERICANS MET TO DEVELOP
LEGISLATION TO CREATE AN
INDEPENDENT GOVERNMENT BODY FOR
THE PROTECTION OF NATIVE
AMERICAN CEMETERIES AND SECRET
PLACES. AS A RESULT OF THESE
MEETINGS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB FORTY TO
THIRTY NINE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KNOCKS
ESTABLISHING THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION
WHICH BECAME IN EFFECT JANUARY
FIRST OF NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN.
THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION CONSIST OF NINE
MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR. AT LEAST FIVE OF THE
NINE MEMBERS MUST CONSIST OF
ELDERS TRADITIONAL PEOPLE OR
SPIRITUAL LEADERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES. THE EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
OF THE COMMISSION IS APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR. THE
LEGISLATION AUTHORIZED THE
COMMISSION TO PROTECT AND
PREVENT IRREPARABLE DAMAGE TO
DESIGNATED SACRED SITES AS WELL
AS TO PREVENT. INFERENCES WITH
THE EXPRESSION OF NATIVE
AMERICAN RELIGION IN CALIFORNIA.
DAMAGE AND ENSURE NATIVE
AMERICAN ACCESS TO SACRED SITES.
AND PREPARE AN INVENTORY OF
NATIVE AMERICAN SACRED SITES
LOCATED ON PUBLIC LANDS AND
REQUIRE THE COMMISSION TO
REVIEW CURRENT ADMINISTRATIVE
AND STATUTORY PROTECTIONS
ACCORDING TO THE SITES. WELL IN
THE FALL OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE COMMUNITY CONSTRUCTION
INCORPORATED UNCOVERED OVER TWO
HUNDRED NATIVE AMERICAN BURIALS
THE BURIAL GROUND HAD BEEN USED
BY THE ME WALK INDIANS UNTIL
THEY WERE DRIVEN OUT OF THE
AREA BETWEEN EIGHTEEN FIFTY AN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY. ONE OF THE
BEAR A DIRECT DESCENDANT OF THE
BURIAL SITE BROUGHT LEGAL
ACTION TO STOP FURTHER
ECALATION AND OTHER
DESECRATION OF THE PROPERTY
BASED ON CEMETERY LAW. WHICH
PROVIDE AIDS. WHICH PROHIBITS
THE DISINTERMENT OF HUMAN
REMAINS WITHOUT AUTHORITY IS
CEMETERIES DEFINED AS SIX OR
MORE HUMAN BODIES BEING BURIED
AT ONE PLACE THE COURT FOUND
THAT INDIANS WERE NOT USING THE
BURIAL GROUND IN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY THREE AND THE SITE
COULD NOT BE CONSIDERED A
CEMETERY. THE COURTS RULED
NATIVE AMERICAN BURIAL GROUNDS
DO NOT QUALIFY A CEMETERY.
ENTITLED TO PROTECTION FROM
DISINTERMENT AND OFFERED NO
PROTECTION FOR NATIVE AMERICAN
BURIAL SITES. AS A RESULT OF
THE JUST US SORRY AS A RESULT
OF THE THIRD DISTRICT COURT OF
APPEALS DECISION SENATOR
GARAMENDI INTRODUCED SB TWO
NINETY SEVEN TO PROVIDE
PROTECTION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
BURIALS AND AMEND THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE FIVE OH NINE
SEVEN POINT NINE EIGHT.
AUTHORIZING THE COMMISSION TO
IDENTIFY THOSE PERSONS. BELIEVE
TO BE THE MOST LIKELY
DESCENDANT FROM THE DECEASED
NATIVE AMERICAN UPON
NOTIFICATION BY A COUNTY
CORONER THAT HUMAN REMAINS HAVE
BEEN DISCOVERED ANY PUBLIC
OTHER PLACE THAN A DEDICATED
CEMETERY. A MOST LIKELY TO SEND
IT WOULD NOW BE GRANTED THE
LEGAL AUTHORITY TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROPERTY
OWNERS REGARDING TREATMENT A
DISPOSITION OF NATIVE AMERICANS
MY REMAINS. AND ASSOCIATED
GRAPEFRUITS. IN JANUARY OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SB. FOUR
FORTY SEVEN AUTHORED BY SENATOR
ELLIS AMENDED THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE FIVE OH NINE
SEVEN POINT NINE NINE MAKING IT
A FELONY TO OBTAIN OR POSSESS
NATIVE AMERICAN HUMOR REMAINS
AND SUCH YOU DID. GOOD. SB
EIGHTEEN WAS AUTHORED BY
SENATOR BURTON WAS INSIDE INTO
LAW IN SEPTEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. SB EIGHTEEN IS
UNIQUE IN THAT IT PROVIDES
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES IN ON AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN LOCAL YANKED
PLAN USED DECISIONS AT AN EARLY
PLANNING STAGE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF PROTECTING AND- OR
MITIGATING. IMPACTS TO CULTURAL
PLACES. SB EIGHTEEN REQUIRES
CITY AND COUNTY GOVERNMENTS TO
CONSULT WITH CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES THEY'RE ON THE
CONTACT LIST MAINTAINED BY THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. PRIOR TO ADOPTION
OR AMENDMENT OF CITY OR COUNTY
GENERAL PLANTS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF PRESERVING SPECIFIC PLACES.
FEATURES AN OBJECTS THAT ARE
LOCATED WITHIN A CITY OR
COUNTIES JURISDICTION.
CONSULTATION OF ALSO RECOGNIZE.
THAT THE TRIBES POTENTIAL NEEDS
FOR CONFIDENTIALITY WITH
RESPECT TO THESE PLACES HAVE A
TRADITIONAL TRIBAL CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE. SB EIGHTEEN
AUTHORIZES THE COMMISSION TO
FACILITATE CONSULTATION BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBE. IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
AB FIFTY TWO AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COTTO AMENDED
SEEK WORK THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT TO
INCLUDE INVOLVEMENT A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES IN THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS WHEN IT COMES TO
IDENTIFYING AND DEVELOPING
MEDICATIONS FOR IMPACTS TO
TRIBAL CULTURAL RESOURCES. AB
FIFTY TO ESTABLISH SICK FORMAL
ROLE FOR CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES IN THE SEQUEL
PROCESS UNDER AB FIFTY TWO
SEQUEL LEAD AGENCIES ARE
REQUIRED TO CONSULT WITH TRIBES
ABOUT POTENTIAL TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES. IN THE PROJECT AREA
THE POTENTIAL SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE PROJECT IMPACTS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A PROJECT
ALTERNATIVES AND THE TYPE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS THAT
SHOULD BE PREPARED. A TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES DEFYING.
SITES FEATURES PLACES CULTURAL
LANDSCAPES AND SACRED PLACES OR
OBJECTS THAT HAVE CULTURAL
VALUE OR SIGNIFICANCE TO TRY
CULTURAL TRIBAL CULTURE
RESOURCES INCLUDE NON UNIQUE
ARCHAEOLOGICAL RESOURCES THAT
INSTEAD OF BEING IMPORTANT FOR
SCIENTIFIC VALUE. AS A RESOURCE
CAN ALSO BE SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
OF THE SACRED AND OR- CULTURAL
TRIBAL VALUE OF THE RESOURCE.
TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVES ARE
CONSIDERED AS EXPERTS
APPROPRIATE FOR PROVIDING
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE REGARDING
THE LOCATION TYPES AND
SIGNIFICANCE OF. I WILL
CULTURAL RESOURCES WITHIN
TRADITIONAL AND CULTURALLY
AFFILIATED GEOGRAPHIC AREA. AB
FIFTY TWO MANDATES LEAD
AGENCIES TO CONSULT WITH
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES ON THE CONTACT LIST
MAINTAINED BY THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION
CONSULTATION SHOULD BE
RECOGNIZED THAT THE TRIBES
POTENTIAL NEED FOR
CONFIDENTIALITY REGARDING THOSE
PLACES THAT WHOLE TRADITIONAL
TRIBAL SIGNIFICANCE INCLUDING
CULTURAL VALUES RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS BELIEFS AND TRADITIONAL
PRACTICES. AB FIFTY TWO
AUTHORIZES THE COMMISSION TO
PROVIDE EACH CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBE A LIST OF ALL
PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT MAY BE A
LEADING SEE UNDER BUT WITH THE
TRIBE'S TRADITIONAL TRIBAL
TERRITORY INCLUDING THE CONTACT
INFORMATION FOR THESE AGENCIES
THE COMMISSION ALSO PROVIDES
INFORMATION ON HOW TRIBES MAY
REQUEST. THE PUBLIC AGENCY TO
NOTIFY. TRIBES WITHIN THE
PROJECT WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION AND ASSIST LEAD
AGENCIES IN IDENTIFYING
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES THAT ARE TRADITIONALLY
AND CULTURALLY AFFILIATED
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION. IN
THIS TEXAS NOW TO IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE THE STATE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICANS. TWENTY FOUR
I'M SORRY TWENTY THIRD HELLO
HELLO NO WHAT I'M STARTING A
TWELVE. AT OKAY LET'S BACK UP.
TWO THOUSAND ONE THE STATE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
GRAVES PROTECTION ACT THIS WAS
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STEINBERG AB FIFTY A NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT CAL NOW PER WAS
TO BE IMPLEMENTED BY AN ACCOUNT
REPATRIATION OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION HOWEVER THE ROUTE.
COMMISSION WAS NEVER FUNDED.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE BESTOWED UPON THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. THE AUTHORITY TO
IMPLEMENT AND ENFORCE COUNTACH
BIRTH THROUGH AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA. CAL NECTAR IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE A SEAMLESS
AND CONSISTENT POLICY TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN HUMOR MEANS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS BE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT. AND APPLY
THE STATE REPATRIATION POLICY
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROVISIONS
OF THE FEDERAL KNACK FOR WHICH
WAS ENACTED INTO I MEAN
NINETEEN NINETY. CAL NARAL PRO
IS INTENDED TO FACILITATE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROVISIONS OF FEDERAL KNACK
PROBE WITH RESPECT TO PUBLICLY
FUNDED AGENCIES IN MUSEUMS IN
CALIFORNIA. PROVIDE A MECHANISM
WHERE A LINEAL DESCENDANTS AND
CULTURALLY AFFILIATED
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES THAT FILE REPATRIATION
CLAIMS FOR HUMOR ROMANCE AND
CULTURAL ITEMS UNDER NECRO WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCIES A
MUSEUM. THEY REQUEST ASSISTANCE
FROM THE COMMISSION IN ENSURING
THAT STATE AGENCIES AND MUSEUMS
ARE RESPONDING TO THOSE CLAIMS
AT A TIMELY MATTER AND
FACILITATING THE RESOLUTION OF
DISPUTES REGARDING THOSE
CLAIMS. AND PROVIDING MECHANISM
OR CALIFORNIA TRIBES THAT ARE
NOT FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED MAY
FILE CLAIMS WITH AGENCIES IN
MUSEUMS. FOR THE REPATRIATION
OF HUMAN REMAINS AND CULTURAL
ITEMS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK OVER THE YEARS TO
MAKE AMERICAN. I KNOW THAT
THEIR JOB WAS VERY MUCH
IMPORTANT HERE WE HAVE
FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE OF. YOUR
WORK FILLING THE SKILLS THAT
ARE THERE ANY IMPORTANT SUBJECT
TO DETECTION. BUT THIS TIME
LIKE HERE FROM. YEAH THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF THAT COMMITTEE I JUST WANTED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS A
HISTORIC ACHIEVEMENT AND I
THINK THAT THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF. A LOT OF WORK
THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO DO TO
REMEDY THE A HISTORICAL
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICANS AND THE STATE
BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS A
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU
TO. LEARN MORE ABOUT THESE
ISSUES AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER TO MOVE
FORWARD AND REALLY DO SOME
PROGRESS OF WORK HERE. THAT'S
THE ONE TECHNOLOGY BEHIND ME
ARE A LOT OF THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE MADE. THE NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION WHAT IT IS
TODAY AND HAVE REALLY BEEN HERE
FOR SUPPORTING THIS WORK FOR
DECADES. AT PRIOR TO MY COMING
ON TO THAT NEED AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION WE HAD A
STAFF OF ABOUT THREE TO FIVE
PEOPLE FOR THE LONGEST TIME AND
WE'RE NOW IN A POSITION LIKE
ARE EXPLAINED IN A FEW MINUTES
WE'RE GONNA. HAVE A STAFF OF
AROUND. THREE TWENTY THREE SO
I'M I'M HERE I'M AGAIN MY NAME
IS CHRISTINA SNYDER I'M THE
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION AND I'M A MEMBER OF
THE DRY CREEK BAND OF POMO
INDIANS IN CINEMA COUNTY I ALSO
SERVICE THE GOVERNOR TRIBAL
ADVISER BUT I'M NOT HERE
WITHOUT HAD BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AS I AS
NEEDED. SO I A QUICK OVERVIEW
OF THE STRATEGIC PLAN THIS WAS
ACTUALLY ADOPTED IN JANUARY
NINETEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN WITH
FORMER CHAIRMEN RAMOS AND UNDER.
ACTING EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
DEBBIE TRIED TRIED HUESO TO THE
EXTENT THAT YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT FORMATION THEY CAN.
ANSWER ALL YOUR QUESTIONS AND
I'M NOT REALLY NECESSARY HERE
BUT PART OF SO WHEN IT WAS
ADOPTED WAS ABOUT A MONTH
BEFORE I CAME ON AS EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY AND THIS HAS BEEN MY
ROAD MAP IN DEVELOPING THE LONG
TERM STRATEGY FOR THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION.
WHEN THE STRATEGIC PLAN WAS
ADOPTED WHICH ALL OF YOU HAVE A
COPY OF IN YOUR AGENDA PACKET
IF YOU WANT TO TAKE A I'M MORE
ON IN DEPTH LOOK. THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF WEAKNESSES OF THE
COMMISSION THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
AND THERE WAS AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THE WORK
OF THE COMMISSION WAS GETTING
INCREASINGLY. BIRD AND- LIKE I
SAID THAT THE COMMISSION STAFF
RANGE FROM ANYWHERE FROM THREE
PEOPLE FOR ABOUT THIRTY YEARS
TO FIVE ASH PEOPLE AND THEN.
HAS TRICKLED UP TO ABOUT NINE
ASH. AND SO THERE WERE AYE BUT-
AS OUR TRIBES HAVE INCREASINGLY
MADE MORE SPACE FOR THEMSELVES
AT THE TABLE IN CALIFORNIA
STATE POLITICS. THERE HAS BEEN.
A LOT MORE INCORPORATION OF THE
LIST THAT WE MAINTAIN IF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION FOR PURPOSES OF
FUNDING STREAMS AND OTHER
ACCESS TO. A COMMITTEES OTHER
LEGISLATIVE ON VEHICLES. AND SO
THERE IS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS ON OUR AGENCY HAS.
MULTIPLIED BY QUITE A LOT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE EFFORTS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE MORE
INCLUSIVE EARLY. AND OF AGENCY
WIDE TO BE MORE INCLUSIVE AND
SO THE THOSE WEAKENED. THAT
AREA OF BEING OVER BURDENED FOR
THE LAWS THAT THIS COMMISSION
ME ARE OVERSEAS WHICH IS ALSO
AT THE BACK OF THIS PACKET
IT'LL LIST ALL OF THE LAWS THAT
WE CURRENTLY OVERSEE AND NOT
ALL OF THOSE ARE ADEQUATELY
BEING. ADDRESSED AT THIS MOMENT
BUT- WITH THAT SAID I'LL GO
THROUGH KIND OF WHAT WE ARE
WHAT THE LONG TERM VISION AS
HOWEVER ADDRESSING AND WHERE
WE'RE AT NOW. THIS FIVE YEAR
PLAN IS INTENDED TO RUN THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO HOPEFULLY
BY THEN I CAN COME BACK AND
REPORT OR MY- WHOEVER ELSE IS
IN THIS POSITION CAN COME BACK
AND REPORT THAT WE'VE CHECKED
EVERYTHING OFF AND WE'RE IN A
GOOD PLACE TO MOVE FORWARD. BUT
FOR NOW I'LL I'LL GIVE YOU KIND
OF A QUICK UPDATE OF WHERE WE
ARE NOW. AND SO IF YOU WANT TO
FOLLOW ALONG THAT COULD BE OVER
ON PAGE TWENTY AT OUR
PRIORITIES GOALS. AND
OBJECTIVES 420-182-2020 TWO. SO
THE FIRST PRIORITY IS FISCAL
STABILITY. THIS COMMISSION
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN. HAS BEEN
SUBJECT TO THE ABS INFLOWS OF
AT AT A CYCLICAL ECONOMY WHICH
EVERY OTHER AGENCY IN
COMMISSION IS AS WELL IN IN
ECONOMIC DOWN TIMES AGENCIES
SUCH AS THE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION ARE SEEN AS MORE
EXPENDABLE I THINK BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND BY THE
ADMINISTRATION SO IT'S NOT ALL
ON YOU ALL BUT I'M- I WHEN WE
NEED TO BE. WHEN WE NEED TO BE
PAYING FOR HEALTH CARE AND
KEEPING PEOPLE ALIVE JUST THIS
WORK GETS DE PRIORITIZED AND SO
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THIS AGENCY HAS BEEN OR
THAT THIS COMMISSION HAS BEEN
WORKING TOWARD IS FIGURING OUT
OTHER SOURCES OF FUNDING
STREAMS SO THAT WE'RE LESS
RELIANT ON THE GENERAL FUND AND
ON THAT FLOWS THE ECONOMY AND
SO. THE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES IT
WOULD BE TO GENERATE ENOUGH
REVENUE THAT APPROPRIATED TO
THE COMMISSION BY THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD SUPPORT
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF THE COST
OF PROGRAM OPERATIONS AT
COMMISSION SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO. ADEQUATELY SPUR OF
THE CULTURE RESOURCES BURIALS
HUMAN REMAINS AND SACRED SITES
THAT WE ARE CHARGED WITH
PROTECTING BY THE STATE SO WITH
THE OBJECTIVES ARE TO IMPLEMENT
LEGISLATION AUTHORIZING THE
COMMISSION TO CHARGE FOR SIX
PLANTS INVENTORY SEARCHES AND
SB A TRIBAL SB EIGHTEEN TRIBAL
CONSULTATION LESS AND SO WE
HAVE THAT AUTHORIZATION WE'RE
JUST IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING REGULATIONS SO. THAT
WE CAN DO IT AND SO WE. OF WHEN
I CAME ON AS AS MANY OF YOU
UNDERSTAND. TRANSITION BETWEEN
ADMINISTRATIONS CAN ALWAYS BE A
LITTLE BIT A LOT OF WORK IN
FIGURING OUT HOW YOU'RE GOING
TO ORIENT AND KIND OF GETTING
EVERYBODY ACCLIMATED AND SO.
WHEN I CAME ON WE WERE ALSO IN
A PLACE OF HAVING OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY STAFF UP THE AGENCY
AND SO WE'VE SHIFTED PRIORITIES
AND NOW WE'RE BACK ON OUR
REGULAR. REGULATIONS WHAT WE'VE
DONE I TO THIS POINT IS EVERY
SINGLE MEMBER OF MY STAFF HAS
GONE TO OUR TRAINING ON
REGULATIONS SO EACH OF THEM CAN
ACTUALLY HOUSE THEM SO THAT WE
CAN KIND OF DO. SEPARATE TRACKS
AT THE SAME TIME SO THESE
REGULATIONS ARE IN ADDITION TO
OTHER REGULATIONS THAT WERE
WORKING ON BUT WILL BE DONE
KIND OF AT THE ON THE SAME
TRACK SO HOPEFULLY WITHIN THE
NEXT. I DON'T WANT TO GIVE YOU
AN ESTIMATE BECAUSE THE STATE
ALWAYS TAKES LONGER THAN I
THINK IT WILL BUT- WITHIN THE
NEAR FUTURE WE SHOULD BE ON A
GOOD IN A GOOD PLACE TO START
WORKING THROUGH THAT
REGULATIONS PROCESS BECAUSE-
BECAUSE OF THE ADDITIONAL.
CONCERNS OF BEING INCLUSIVE AND
HAVING BROAD BASED CONSULTATION
WITH TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. THOSE
TIME LINES ARE NECESSARILY MUCH
LONGER BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WHATEVER WE COME UP
WITH ACCURATELY ACCURATELY
REFLECTS WHAT THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS WANT. AND SO I.
THAT'S IN PROCESS. THE SPECIAL
INTERESTS LICENSE PLATE
CAMPAIGN. IS ACTUALLY PRETTY
MUCH READY WE'RE JUST. THE
TIMING WISE BIRD WERE HAVING A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT RELEASES
BUT THE BIGGER RELEASE WILL BE
ON NATIVE AMERICAN DAY. WHICH
THIS COMMITTEE AS IT HAS BEEN
VERY ACTIVE AND THE CHAIRMAN
HAS BEEN VERY ACTIVE AND SO THE
BIG RELEASE WHEN YOU CAN SIGN
UP AND PURCHASE A SPECIAL.
SPECIAL INTERESTS LICENSE
PLATE. IS GOING TO BE ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHTH WHICH
IS MADE AMERICAN DAY. YOU CAN
KIND OF DO IT BEFORE THEN I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE READY
TO TAKE THOSE ORDERS OF THIS
WEEK BUT I'M NOT GONNA COMMIT
TO ANYTHING JUST IN CASE
SOMETHING HAPPENS. AND THOUGH
IT. I THE COMMISSION ITSELF
VOTED ON PRIORITY PROGRAMS AND
AREAS TO FOR THAT THAT LICENSE
PLATE WITH FINE SO IT DOESN'T
GO TO JUST RANDOM STUFF THAT
GOES TO ACTUAL. WORK ON SITE
PROTECTION AS BE EIGHTEEN IT
GOES TO A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
THINGS RELATED TO THE CORE LOOK
AT THE COMMISSION. ARE THOSE
LICENSE PLATES FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVEN'T SEEN THEM. HI THERE
AT PROTECT NATIVE CULTURE DOT
COM AND IN ORDER THERE AS WELL
AND THEY HAVE EIGHTY OKAY. GET
WHICH WAS DONATED. IT'S NOT A
FORMER EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
ISN'T AT GOT AS. ON HIS ON
EVERYBODY KIND OF SUPPORTING
THIS BECAUSE COLLECTIVELY AS A
STATE AND AS CONSTITUENTS IN AS
MEMBERS OF THIS PLACE BUT WE
NOW CALL CALIFORNIA. WE THINK
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
EVERYBODY PRIORITIZE IS THIS
WORKING KNOWLEDGE IS WHO IS WHO
IS HERE PRIOR TO STATEHOOD SO.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO GO BUY ONE
GET GET IT PERSONALIZED. GET
WHATEVER. GET WHATEVER NATIVE
WORD OR TRIBE YOU WANT TO GET
ON THERE BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
START GETTING. YOU KNOW BOOKED
UP AND YOU MAY HAVE TO BE LIKE.
I'M A PRINCESS TEN OR SOMETHING
SO. AND THEN FINALLY AT. IN
EXPLORING OTHER ADDITIONAL
FUNDING STRATEGIES WE HAVEN'T
GOTTEN TO THIS PART YET. AND
THIS IS CHARGING STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR
TRAININGS. APPLYING FOR GRANTS
AND CHARGING FOR PUBLICATIONS
LIKE THE CULTURE RESOURCES
HANDBOOK BITES THAT SAID. WE
HAVE PULLED UP THE OLD CULTURE
RESOURCES HANDBOOK TO THAT BUT
WITH THAT LIKE TWENTY YEARS AGO
DEBBIE YEAH. NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
ABOUT TWO MORE AT BATS LIKE
THIRTY YEARS AGO. SO IT'S LIKE
TWENTY TO ME. DEBBIE IS ONE OF
OUR OUR BEST RESOURCES BECAUSE
OF JUST THE COMMITMENT SHE
THOUGHT TO THE AGENCY WORK ON
THE COMMISSION FOR THIRTY
YEARS. SO SHE WAS THERE WHEN WE
HAD OUR LAST CALL FOR RESOURCES
HAND BACK OUT AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA TAKE THAT WE'RE
GONNA REFRESH IT AND HOPEFULLY
THAT'LL ALSO BE ON. CALL SERVE
THE PURPOSE OF SUSTAINING THE
COMMISSION BUT ALSO. OF HELPING
TO BE A RESOURCE TO EDUCATE THE
PUBLIC AND STATE AGENCIES AND
LOCAL AGENCIES ON THE LAWS THAT
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR. SO
PRIORITY TO SUCCESSION
RETENTION PLANNING AND
RECRUITMENT. I'M THE ISSUE HERE
WAS. PRIOR TO JOINING THE
COMMISSION THE COMMISSION HAD
AGAIN I. KNOW THREE TO FIVE
STAFF AT SOMETIMES. LIKE A V.
IN THE BLAST YEARS UP TO NINE.
HAD A FLAT STRUCTURE AND SO.
WAS SEEN AS IF YOU GOT A
POSITION WITHIN THE COMMISSION
THERE WAS NOT REALLY ANYWHERE
TO GO EXCEPT TO PROMOTE IN
PLACE IF YOU REALLY WANTED TO
STAY AND YOU REALLY WANT TO BE
COMMITTED TO THIS WORK. WHAT
WE'VE DONE NOW AND YOU CAN LOOK
ON THE LAST PAGE IS ACTUALLY A
PROPOSED ORG CHART. AND WE
ACTUALLY MESSED WITH THIS A
LITTLE BIT. BASED ON AND- ON
AND. ON THE BUDGET PROCESS
BASICALLY SO IT LOOKS DIFFERENT
NOW BUT AS ADOPTED IT IS
BASICALLY LIKE A TOP DOWN
STRUCTURE WHERE THERE ARE
PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO KIND OF
JUMP AROUND IF THEY WANT TO
BUILD THEIR SKILLS AND STAY
WITH THE AGENCY LONG TERM. SO
PART OF WHAT WE'VE DONE AND
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
ESTABLISHING A LOT OF POSITIONS
WHICH TAKES QUITE SOME TIME BY
IT. WILL HAVE EIGHTY CHIEF
DEPUTY THAT WILL OVERSEE THEM
BY THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEPARTMENT
AND THAT'S THE EVERY DAY LIKE.
IF A STATE AGENCY OR A LEAD
AGENCY NEEDS TIME TO FIGURE OUT
WHO TO CONTACT WHICH TRIBES TO
CONTACT THE CONTACT THAT
DEPARTMENT. AND THAT'S
BASICALLY THE BULK OF OUR DAY
TO DAY WORK WE WILL ALSO BE
ESTABLISHING A CHIEF COUNSEL
POSITION WHICH WILL OVERSEE ALL
OF THE LEGAL PROGRAMS
INCLUDING. WE HAVE A NUMBER
WHICH I'LL- I'LL TALK ABOUT NOW
ACTUALLY OF AT CLINICS THAT WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED WITHIN THE UC
SYSTEM AHMED AT SEVERAL LAW
SCHOOLS. AND BUT ALSO THE
LITIGATION ANY SORT OF
SETTLEMENTS THAT WE ARE LOOKING
AT ANY SORT OF ENFORCEMENT THAT
THE AGENCY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
AND SO LONG TERM THE IDEA IS TO
YOU REALLY CREATE THE CAPACITY
TO TAKE ON ALL OF THIS WORK IN
A WAY THAT IS THOUGHTFUL AND-
BROAD BASED. AND SO RIGHT NOW
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF HIRING
OP AND WE ARE WE HAVE CREATED
CAREER PATHS THAT MAKES SENSE
TO SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO MAKE A
CAREER OUT OF THIS. LIKE I
MENTIONED WHEN I CAME ON THE
PREVIOUS EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
HAD ALREADY ESTABLISHED A SMALL
CLINIC AT UCLA LAW I THAT I IT.
WAS GOING TO DO A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT BASICALLY FOR THE
LOS ANGELES AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREAS. BY ONE OF OUR
COMMISSIONERS COMMISSIONER
MARANDA AT LIVE DOT INITIATIVE
LAST YEAR AND HAS DEVELOPED
SOME REALLY GOOD. SOME GOOD
CAPACITY BUILDING MATERIALS FOR
SOME OF THE TRIBES IN THE AREA.
THIS YEAR UCLA LAW WAS BLESSED
WITH A SIGNIFICANT. I. BRUNEI
GUYS IN CREATING A LONG TERM
SYSTEMIC. CLINIC UNDER THE
DIRECTION I'M SAN MANUEL SO
SOME OF THE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT'S
GOING TO MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE
IN INDIAN COUNTRY BECAUSE IT'S
NOT JUST FOCUSED ON TRIBAL
CULTURE RESOURCES IT'S
EVERYTHING BUT WE STILL HAVE A
LITTLE BIT THAT WE- SEND TO
UCLA SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE CULTURAL RESOURCE.
THAT CULTURAL RESOURCE WORK IS
STILL DONE SO I SPOKE WITH THAT
NEW DIRECTOR LEARNED AND HEALTH
CARD SHE'S A FORMER CLASSMATE
OF MINE ACTUALLY AND- SHE IS
GOING TO BE. LOOKING AT HOW WE
CAN BETTER SERVE I'D AND BUILD
UP CAPACITY FOR TRIBES LIKE THE
NON FIRE RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
THE AREA AND SOME OF THE TRIBES
WITH FEWER RESOURCES AND- SO
SHE'S GOING TO REACHING OUT TO
SOME OF THE TRIBES THAT HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN CREATING
MATERIALS LIKE PREMEDICATION
PLANS. AND LOOKING AT HOW.
THOSE STUDENTS CAN ALSO PROVIDE
TRAININGS TO OUTSIDE OF THE
CONTEXT OF THE STATE AND SO.
LONG TERM PLAN IS TO CREATE
MORE CAPACITY BUT ALSO EDUCATE
THE STUDENTS ON THE THESE BODY
OF LAWS SO IN THE EVENT THAT
THEY DID WANT TO COME WORK FOR
THE COMMISSION OR IN HOUSE FOR
TRIBES AND BUILD THOSE THAT
CAPACITY THAT WE ARE.
INOCULATING THE STUDENTS WITH
THE KNOWLEDGE THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO NAVIGATE WORKING WITH
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS ON THIS
INCREDIBLY SENSITIVE AREA. I'M
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE CLINICS
THIS YEAR WE REACH AN AGREEMENT
WITH UC BERKELEY. AND THEY WILL
BE HIRING A STAFF ATTORNEY TO
OVERSEE A PRO BONO PROGRAM THAT
WILL BE DOING SIMILAR WORK IN
THE BAY AREA AND I'VE
IDENTIFIED A FEW TRIBES THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN HAVING STUDENTS
COME IN HOUSE AND HELP THEM
DEVELOP THEIR CULTURAL RESOURCE
PROGRAMS AND SO THAT'S PROBABLY
GOING TO BE UP AND RUNNING BY
JANUARY. WITH THE IDEA THAT
EVENTUALLY IT'LL TURN INTO A
FULL FLEDGED PROGRAM AS WELL UC
DAVIS AS WELL UNDER THE
DIRECTION OF JUDGE CHRISTINE
WILLIAMS FROM IRAQ IS ALSO
TAKING ON SOME OF THIS WORK SO
WE'RE HOPING TO BOTH ADDRESS
CAPACITY FOR TRIBES THAT ARE
NOT ABLE TO HAVE FULL CULTURE
RESOURCE TEAMS AND HOUSE. BUT
ALSO TO HELP BUILD UP THE BODY
OF KNOWLEDGE IN THIS AREA SO
THAT WE CAN. CREATE MORE OF A
PIPELINE INTO THIS WORK. WE ARE
BRINGING ON A LEGAL FELLOW THIS
FALL FOR ME STILL ALLIES WHILE
AND THEN I'M I'VE MADE IT. THE
OFFER OPEN TO EACH OF THESE
CLINICS THAT. IF THERE ARE
STUDENTS THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
THIS WORK OR AND SOME OF THE
BROADER. BODY OF TRIBAL POLICY
WORK ARM. UNDER MY OTHER HAT
THAT I'M WILLING TO TAKE ON
SHADOWING AND- OTHER OTHER. I
CAN USE ALL THE HELP I CAN GET.
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE WE'RE AT
IS TRYING TO CREATE. A
BASICALLY. PIPELINE IS NOT THE
RIGHT WORD BECAUSE WE YEAH IT'S
NOT. IT'S NOT THAT IN THIS CASE
BUT I FIVE. I'D LIKE TO CREATE
A PATH TO BUILD UP THE BODY
THIS WORKING AND HAVE MORE
PEOPLE HELPING US DO THE HEAVY
LIFTING SO THAT'S IN PROCESS.
AND I WILL WE HAVE JUST A FEW
MORE. PRIORITIES. WE'RE ALSO
WORKING ON AND BUILDING UP THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO STAFF IN
THE EVENT OF TURNOVER AND
TRAINING MATERIALS SO WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND HOUSE IS THAT
WERE STANDARDISING ALL OF OUR
PER PROCEDURES ARE PROCESSES
WERE UPDATING FORMS WERE ALSO
OPEN TO IF TRIBES FEEL LIKE
THINGS ARE NOT WORKING WE WANT
TO KNOW THAT BECAUSE- WE WERE
NOT THE ONES THAT HAVE TO
NAVIGATE THESE LAWS WE JUST TRY
TO MAKE IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE
BUT WE DON'T ALWAYS KNOW WHAT
IS THE STICKING POINT AND SO.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF UPDATING A LOT OF OUR INTAKE
FORMS BUT ALSO ON THE BACK AND
CREATING PROCESSES SO THAT
NEWER STAFF CAN JUST KIND OF
BASICALLY LOOK AT A CHECKLIST
OF THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT WHEN
THEY'RE DETERMINING CERTAIN
THINGS LIKE MOST LIKELY JUST
DESCENDANTS. OR AREAS OF
INTEREST AND THAT WE WERE NOT
PEOPLE LIKE DEBBIE CAN ALSO
RETIRE EVENTUALLY. AND SO STAND
RISING PROCESSES AND THEN ALSO.
WHAT WE'RE DOING INTERNALLY IS
AT OUR STAFF MEETINGS ARE
HAVING INTERNAL TRAININGS ON
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE DO
AND WE'RE FILMING THOUGH SO
THAT WHEN WE DO ON BOARD
PEOPLE. THEY CAN JUST TAKE A
LOOK AT NOT A DIFFERENT STAFF
TIME FOR THAT AS WELL. SO THE
THIRD PRIORITY ON PAGE TWENTY
SIX IS INCREASED INTERNAL
COMPLIANCE. AND SO. CREATING AN
INTERNAL COMPLIANCE CALENDAR
AND CHECKLIST AND SO WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A CHECKLIST OF
ALL OF THIS STRATEGIC PLAN TO
SEE WHERE WE'RE AT AND WHETHER
WE'RE HEADING OR BENCHMARKS.
ADOPT REGULATIONS AGAIN WE HAVE
ABOUT WHAT SIX THAT THE
REGULATIONS THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY GOING TO BE. WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF ASSESSING WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE BY EACH OF THE
STAFF AT EACH OF THE
REGULATIONS HAS A SENIOR STAFF
AND A JUNIOR STAFFER ASSIGNED
TO IT. TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
GET THROUGH WITH THE IDEA THAT
ALL OF THESE NEED TO BE TO GO
THROUGH LEGAL I'M- A AT HIGHS
AS WELL BUT WE WERE ADVISED BY
SOME OF OUR SISTER AGENCIES
THAT. IT'S ACTUALLY BETTER TO
HAVE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY WORKING ON ALL OF THE
SPECIFIC REGULATIONS AND HAVING
TO NAVIGATE IT HELP. SHEPHERD
THOUGHT SO THAT THEY CAN. MAKE
REGULATIONS THAT ACTUALLY MAKE
SENSE FOR THE SPECIFIC THING SO
THAT'S KIND OF. WHERE WE ARE
WITH THAT. WE'RE INCREASING
STAFFING TO MAINTAIN INTERNAL
COMPLIANCE. AND IMPLEMENTING
CAL NOT PRO WE JUST HIRED OR WE
JUST CONTRACTED WITH CALIFORNIA
ANY LEGAL SERVICES TO HELP US
DO THAT CALIFORNIA ANY LEGAL
SERVICES FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT
ARE AND WHERE IS. A AN OUTSIDE
LAW FIRM THAT IS DEDICATED TO
SERVING TRIBES KIND OF AS A NON
PROFIT AND SO THEY HELP A LOT
OF THAT THE NEED YOUR TRIBES
BUT ALSO WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR A
LOT OF THE ARM. MANY OF THE
TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA WERE
TERMINATED DURING THE
TERMINATION ERA THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SOME OF THE
LITIGATION THAT. BROUGHT THEM
BACK SO THEY HAVE DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING ON SOME OF
THESE MORE SENSITIVE ISSUES AND
WE'RE EXCITED TO HAVE THEM ON
AND THINK THAT THEY'LL DO A
REALLY GOOD JOB AND- IN
DEVELOPING. THE COUNT ACT PRESS.
BODY I HAVE. WE'RE LOOKING AT
IT AS KIND OF US ACROSS AYE
ADMINISTRATIVE JUDICIAL PROCESS
WHERE WILL BE PROCESSING CLAIMS
IN HOUSE AND SO THAT'S PART OF
WHY WE'RE BUILDING UP OUR LEGAL
DEPARTMENT AS WELL. BUT SO
THEY'LL BE KIND OF SHEPHERDING
THOUGHT PROCESS AND THEN THE
FOURTH PRIORITY INCREASED
TRAINING FOR STAFF TRIED AND
STAKEHOLDERS. WERE DOING THAT
AND KIND OF A LAYERED WAY LIKE
I SAID THE UC'S ARE GOING TO BE
DOING A LOT OF THE YEAH.
TRAININGS FOR TRIBES AND MAKING
SURE THAT THEY HAVE THAT
CAPACITY AND THE WHERE WITH ALL
TO BE ABLE TO NAVIGATE THESE
LAWS I'M GOING TO BE. I DON'T
KNOW IF I SHOULD SAY THIS ON
THE RECORD BUT WHEN I DO HIRED.
WHAT I DO HIGHER. WHATEVER IT'S
NOT LIKE IT'LL POP UP LATER IN
MY CAREER. WHAT I DO HIGHER
DEPUTY FOR MY TRIBAL ADVISER
POSITION I'VE I TENTATIVELY
REACHED OUT TO THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH WHICH WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR TUNING DOING
THE TRAININGS ON AB FIFTY TWO
STATEWIDE INITIALLY. I AM AND
I'M HOPING TO HAVE MY DEPUTY
SET THEIR PART TIME I'M SO THAT
THEY CAN KIND OF. HELP THEM
REINVIGORATE THAT PROGRAM TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE NEEDED TO
HAVE MORE TRAINING FROM A LOCAL
AND STATE LEVELS BECAUSE IT HAS
BEEN A FEW YEARS BEFORE SINCE
WE'VE DONE THAT AND SO.
EVERYTHING OWLS WERE STILL
WORKING ON AND IT IS A FIVE
YEAR PLAN I'VE ONLY BEEN HERE A
YEAR AND A HALF SO PLEASE HAVE
SOME PATIENCE WITH ME BUT WE
ARE. WE DO HAVE WIFI NOW WHICH
IS GREAT. WE'RE EXPANDING INTO
THE BUILDING THAT WERE AND SO
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE BASICALLY IN
A REALLY GOOD PLACE TO LAUNCH
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS TO
COMPLETE THIS THIS PLAN AND SO.
IT IS THERE SOME GROWING PAINS
AND IT'S TAKING SOME TIME BUT I
AM VERY CONFIDENT THAT. THAT WE
CAN ACHIEVE. THE GOALS IN THE
PRINCIPLES OUTLINED IN HERE AND
HOPEFULLY BUILD ON THE GOOD
WORK OF FORMER CHAIRMAN RAMOS.
AND THE REST OF THE COMMISSION
THAT HAS BEEN. CHUGGING ALONG
FOR SOME TIME WITH A LITTLE
HELP IN LITTLE RESOURCES. HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THOSE
PRESENTATIONS WE DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SOME OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT JOINED
US LORETTA GONZALEZ ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MONIQUE LIMON. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. JIM COOPER.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA
RUBIO. SO THE PANEL THIS
DISCUSSION IS ON THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION
THE OVERSIGHT THAT'S THERE
THERE'S AN IMPORTANT KEY THAT
YOU BROUGHT UP BUT IS THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME. SO
REMEMBER. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
AND THANK YOU FOR HOSTING THIS
AGAIN HISTORIC HEARING I THANK
YOU TO BOTH OF OUR WITNESSES MR
WAY FOR THE HISTORIC
PERSPECTIVE AND THEN BESIDE A
FOR A VERY COMPREHENSIVE LOOK
AT WHAT YOU'RE DOING I MEAN I'M
I'M REALLY IMPRESSED BY WHAT
ALL IS GOING ON FIRST QUESTION
WHO'S THE CHAIRPERSON NOW THAT
MR HOME IS THAT IT. I'D HAVE TO
ASK THE DIFFICULT QUESTIONS WE
HAVE AN ACTING CHAIR PERSON WHO
IS LARA MARANDA FROM PITANGA WE
WILL EVENTUALLY HOLD AN
ELECTION PROBABLY AT THE NEXT
MEETING BUT WE'RE ALSO BACK
FILLING FROM THE VACANCY OKAY
IN A SPEECH TO A YOU KNOW HE HE
HE MADE MENTION WOULD BEEN
DISCUSSING THE LICENSE PLATE IN
THE INTERNAL POLITICS OF INDIAN
COUNTRY AND I ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND THAT WITH REGARD TO
DIVERSITY BOTH OF THE
COMMISSION AND IF SOME OF THE
COMMITTEES AND INFORM THE
COMMISSION OR ADVISE THE
COMMISSION. WHAT EFFORTS
UNDERTAKEN TO TRYING GET
GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY I
RECOGNIZE IT CAN BE DIFFICULT
TO FIND PEOPLE WHO ARE WILLING
AND QUALIFIED AND ABLE AND ALL
THAT KIND OF STUFF BUT THERE'S
ALSO GEOGRAPHIC DIFFERENCES SO
WITH IN SAN DIEGO WE ARE
BLESSED WITH MANY MANY
DIFFERENT TRIBES AND THAT ALSO
HAVE SOME OF THOSE INTERNAL
DIVISIONS CAN YOU SPEAK TO WHAT
EFFORTS IF ANY ARE BEING MADE
TO TRY AND MAKE SURE THE
COMMISSION ITSELF HAS
GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY. IN TERMS
OF THE- OF NATIVE
REPRESENTATION. SURE AND SO THE
COMMISSION IS THAT ARE A
GOVERNOR APPOINTED COMMISSION
SO. KIND OF FREE EXECUTIVE
ORDER BE TEN ELEVEN EDGE BUT
PROBABLY LATER THAN THAT EVEN.
I THINK THAT WELL I CAN'T SPEAK
TO WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE BUT THE-
STATES UNDERSTANDING OF THE
COMPLEXITY AND DIVERSITY OF
INDIAN COUNTRY WAS PROBABLY THE.
AND NOT TO AT AT TO ANYONE'S
FAULT I THINK THAT THERE IS
JUST YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
DON'T KNOW WAS LESS DEVELOPED
AND I THINK MOVING FORWARD THIS
GOVERNOR IS COMMITTED TO
FINDING. I GEOGRAPHICALLY
DIVERSE CANDIDATES SIMILAR TO
IF YOU'LL LOOK AT THE TRIBAL
NATIONS GRANT FINDS WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A MEMBER HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE TODAY. TO I THINK
MAYBE I'M SPEAKING ON THE
PANELS WELL BUT- I. FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OUR
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT WE WANT TO
BE AS INCLUSIVE AND DIVERSE AS
POSSIBLE SO. MOVING FORWARD WE
NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE WITH THIS
COMMISSION SPECIFICALLY BUT WE
ARE COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE LISTENING TO TRIBES
AND WHERE POSSIBLE TRYING TO.
ACCOUNT FOR CULTURAL
DIFFERENCES WHILE BEING IN LINE
WITH THE MANDATES OF THE
STATUTE. IN I RECOGNIZE
PRECARIOUS SITUATION A LOT OF
COMPETING FACTORS I JUST OF
THAT BIG BIG JUST FROM WHAT THE
CUT THE COUNTY I REPRESENT WE
KNOW THIS IS THE THING. IT'S
HARD TO DO WITH NINE POSITIONS
AND WITHIN THE NIAGARA
COMMITTEE IN OTHERS AND YOU
JUST IT'S OF IT'S A THREAD
THAT'S THROUGHOUT THE STRATEGIC
PLANNING SHE MENTION OF REALLY
DOING A LOT OF OUT REACH A LOT
OF TRAINING. AND ONE ON MY HOPE
BUT I HOPE IS AMONG THE MANY
THINGS THAT WILL COME FROM THAT
IS OPPORTUNITY GET MORE PEOPLE
INVOLVED. AND I YOU MENTION
THESE ARE GOING TO TWELVE POINT
HE'S AND I THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
PROVEN HIS UNDERSTANDING
CONCERN IN AND WILLINGNESS TO
ACT FOR CALIFORNIA'S NATIVES.
OF THROUGH THE ISSUING OF THE
OF THE APOLOGY WHICH IS
INCREDIBLE GESTURE AND ONE THAT
NOW NEEDS TO BE BACKED UP WITH
ACTION WHICH IS THE FIRST TO
NOTICE THAT AND I THINK YOUR
PRESENCE IN THIS PLAN. INDICATE
THAT THAT'S MORE THAN APOLOGY
THIS IT'LL ACTION IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY SB FOR MY
COLLEAGUES AT WORK FOR GAME TO
DO OUR PART TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE. WRITING PAST WRONGS I'M
AN AVID LASTLY JUST SAY IN THIS
REGARD THERE'S A LIST OF GROUP
POLICIES THAT THE SUBSEQUENT. I
DID SPEAK TO THIS BUT TO BE
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THIS IS FAR
BEYOND GAMING RIGHT THIS IS A
BALLOT QUALITY OF LIFE WRITING
HISTORIC INJUSTICES THE
TREMENDOUS POVERTY AND OTHER
SOCIAL CHALLENGES THAT ARE
UNIQUE TO INDIAN COUNTRY. AND
BEFORE AGAIN WHY THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING IS SO IMPORTANT I WOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT MOST PEOPLE
THINK THAT THAT OUR CONCERN AND
INTEREST IS IN A VERY NARROW
BAND I THINK RECENT LEGISLATIVE
EXPERIENCE AS IT TO ADD
MENTIONED. IN IN YOUR TESTIMONY
IS A TRIED WAY WE'RE TRYING TO
WORKING DIRECTIONS. AROUND
CULTURAL ADORNMENTS
REPATRIATION AND SO ON. SO FOR
IT. I THINK THE CALL OUT FROM
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY SHOULD BE
TO EVERY CALIFORNIA NATIVE AND
THEIR SUPPORTERS TO GIVE US
ADDITIONAL IDEAS OF THE WORK
THAT MUST BE DONE. BECAUSE WE
HAVE A AGENCY THAT'S WILLING TO
DO WORK WE HAVE A EXECUTIVE
THAT'S ANIMATED AND LIVE A
LEGISLATURE THAT'S WILLING TO
DO IT AND FOR TOO LONG A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES NOT BEEN ADDRESSED
NOW'S THE TIME START WORKING ON
THEM SO. THANK YOU FOR THIS
COMMENT LAWMAKERS COMES
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO MEMBER
GLORIA. ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WISH MAKE ON. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA. I'M. WANT TO
JOIN IN AND RECOGNIZING HOW IS
A STORY THIS IS AS THE FIRST
SELECT COMMITTEE ON ON NATIVE
AMERICAN FAIRS AND IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND VERY PLEASED
TO HEAR HOW THE PROGRESS MADE
BY THE THAT THE COMMISSION. AND
ABILITY TO EXPAND AND EXPAND
THE SCOPE AND WORK. AS AS THE
CHAIR OF HIGHER EDUCATION
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ON AT UC BERKELEY
AND THE REMAINS AT UC BERKELEY
IS THAT AN ISSUE THAT IS
ADDRESSED BY THE COMMISSION. WE
ARE ADDRESSING IT. SORT OF
THROUGH THE STRATEGIC PLAN PART
OF WHY I WE REACHED OUT TO UC
BERKELEY ALLOTTED TO CREATE THE
FIRST ACT CLINIC THERE IS TO
BUILD IN SOME OF THAT
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE SO THAT
YOU THEIR SISTER AT UC BERKELEY
UNDERGRAD AND THOSE DEPARTMENTS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HAVE A
RESOURCE WHERE THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE GOING TO THEM AND
KIND OF SORTING THROUGH THESE
ISSUES SO THAT THEY CAN BE MORE
RESPECTFUL OF THE LAWS THAT
THERE THEY SHOULD BE COMPLYING
WITH. ANOTHER WAY THAT WE'RE
ENGAGED IS UNDER ON AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY SIX WHICH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA AT SPONSORED LAST
YEAR I WE'RE ASSISTING IN THOSE
EFFORTS TO CREATE A SYSTEM WIDE
YOU SEEN I POLICY BUT ALSO A
SYSTEM WIDE UC. MADE AMERICAN
POLICY AND SO. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE ALL OF THE
REALLY GOOD TRIBAL KNOW HOW ON
THOSE COMMITTEES AND SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE NEED TO TâM AND
WHAT THEY'VE DONE SO FAR JUST
TO MAKE IT SO THAT IT'S IN LINE
WITH THE REALITY OF HOW WE
OPERATE ON THE STATE SIDE I'M
HAPPY TO DO THAT BUT I HAVE
EVERY TRUSTS ALL THE PRESS IN
THE WORLD WITH THE COMMITTEES
THAT HAVE A NUMBER OF TRIBAL
CHAIRMAN. I DIRECTING AND THAT
WORK AND THEY ACTUALLY ARE
PRODUCING SOME SOME GOOD WORK
THAT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO SHARE
PUBLICLY I THINK IN THAT IN THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS AND SO WE ARE
VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON THAT AND
ESPECIALLY NOW THAT WE'RE THE
COMMISSION I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR.
CAL MAG PRIOR WHICH REQUIRES
REPATRIATION OF HUMAN REMAINS
AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE OF GUIDES
FROM BASICALLY ALL STATE
MUSEUMS WHICH INCLUDES THE UC'S
ON SOME SENSE AS I THINK THAT
PART OF WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE THE USE YOU TO DO IS
JUST DO THE RIGHT THING WITHIN
THE SPIRIT OF THE LAW AS WELL
AND SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN YOU
KNOW WORK TOGETHER IN
COLLABORATION AND GET. THE
BIGGER ISSUE I THINK IS MORE OF
THE CULTURAL SHIFT AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S A STATEWIDE ISSUE
TO BE HONEST SO THE MORE THAT
ALL OF US CAN EMBRACE THE
SPIRIT OF RESPECT FOR NATIVE
PEOPLES BUT ALSO NATIVE REMAINS.
THEN WILL BE GONE IN A GOOD
DIRECTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WENDY CARILLO AT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. CAN
SOMEONE OR GLORIA COULD WE DO
SOMETHING LAST YEAR WITH
REGARDS ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
MOAN LAST YEAR. ON WRITING A
LETTER OF SUPPORT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE UC'S WERE GIVING BACK
SOME OF THE. SO WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S THE STATUS ON MATTER HOW
CAN HOW CAN BE MORE SO HOW CAN
WE BE MORE SUPPORTIVE. I THINK
WE'RE STILL WE'RE IN A GOOD
PLACE WE'VE GOT THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTENTION PRESENT APOLOGY.
ACTUALLY CONVENE A PRESIDENT'S
YOU SEE ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
NATIVE AMERICAN ISSUES. AND
MATT ODD I THINK THE LAST DAY
IN JANUARY AND SO THAT. THAT
COMMITTEE ITSELF IS MEETING
QUARTERLY TO DISCUSS NOT JUST
REPATRIATION ISSUES BY THINGS
LIKE OUR RETENTION OF
CALIFORNIA NATIVE STUDENTS. AND
OTHER ISSUES ON LIKE HIRING AND
ALL OF THAT THAT CREATE
CONDITIONS THAT MAKE IT LESS
ATTRACTIVE FOR NATE. TO WANT TO
STAY IN THOSE SCHOOLS. SO IT'S
WORKING ON KIND OF THE BODY OF
WORK AND THEN ALSO EACH YOU SEE
IS GOING TO HAVE TO. ADOPT A
POLICY AS WELL ON THIS ON BOTH
ON THIS AND THAT THANK YOU FOR
NOT PAYING CAL NOT PRO WORK
WHICH IS THE REPATRIATION WORK.
BY THAT COMMITTEE CREATED A SUB
COMMITTEE THAT'S CHARGED WITH
CREATING WITH THE SYSTEM WIDE
POLICY WHICH IS. ALMOST FINAL
AT THIS POINT SO THINGS ARE
PROGRESSING INTO AN INCREDIBLY
POSITIVE WAY THE GROUP THAT HAS
BEEN ASSEMBLED AS-
REPRESENTATIVE OF. BOTH AT THE
DIVERSITY OF GEOGRAPHY BUT ALSO
OF THE RECOGNIZED AND NOT
RECOGNIZE TRIES TO HAVE
INTEREST IN THIS WORK SO. IT'S
MOVING IT'S GOT THE ATTENTION
OF THE PRESIDENT AND SHE'S MADE
HERSELF AVAILABLE AND. AND HAS
REALLY I SUPPORT THIS WORK AT
ALL. THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT
IN A IN THERE IS A BILL THAT
MYSELF AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA DID CO AUTHOR TOGETHER
BECAUSE THAT SIGNED INTO. LAW
BY THE GOVERNOR BEFORE WE WENT
ON. SUMMER RECESS TO ADD
ANOTHER NATIVE AMERICAN TO THE
YOU SEE NOW PRO BOARD SO THAT
WE'RE DOING THAT WORK MAKING
SURE THAT THAT THE- THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS WELL BALANCED WITH
NATIVE AMERICANS ON IT. SO
THERE IS STILL WORK THAT THAT'S
BEING DONE. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND
BRINGING UP THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION IN THE STREAM OF
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH ALL
CALIFORNIA DO PEOPLE AND TO
REITERATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER A
GLORIOUS COMMENTS THIS IS FAR
MORE THAN THAN THE GAMING
ISSUES THAT ARE AFFECTING
TRAVEL PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S WITH THE
SELECT COMMITTEE. IS
ESTABLISHED TO DO IS TO LOOK AT
THOSE PARADIGMS THERE WHAT WE
NEED THE SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN TO HAVE THE
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS WITH THE
LEGISLATORS THAT ARE HERE SO
THANK YOU AGAIN CRISTINA SNYDER
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND W.
TREADWAY FOR YOUR YOUR LONG
SERVICE TO THE NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION INTO THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NEXT PANEL THAT
WE'RE WE ARE GOING TO BE
BRINGING UP. IS ISSUES
IMPACTING CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES IN THE FIRST
PANEL THAT WILL BE COMING UP
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE ACTED DEBT
EPIDEMIC OF MISSING AND
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
AND GIRLS. THE SPEAKERS WILL BE
MISS LORI GONZALEZ COUNCIL
WOMAN FROM THE RING CONN BAND
OF THE ST YOU INDIANS. WE ALSO
HAVE SPEAKERS MISS DESTINY
DURO. MISSED RAVEN COSSUS AND
MISS ANNABELLE HERNANDEZ FROM
THE SALMON WELL BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS SO WE COULD HAVE THEM
COME FORWARD. THANK YOU
. THANK
YOU AND THIS IS A VERY. TOPIC
THAT REALLY ADDRESSES ON
CALIFORNIAN PEOPLE HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
ADDRESSES A NATIONWIDE EPIDEMIC
THAT ALSO NEEDS TO HAVE.
ADVOCACY IN ATTENTION TO NAY
GOES SOME HAND IN HAND WITH THE
GOVERNOR SOME EXECUTIVE ORDER
OF APOLOGIES OF ATROCITIES IN
GENOCIDE TOWARDS CALIFORNIAN TO
PEOPLE IN THE HISTORY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT IT ALSO
BRINGS. TWO FOUR FOUR FRUITION
THE IMPORTANCE AND ACADEMIC
EPIDEMIC THAT STILL CONTINUES
TO PLAGUE INDIAN COUNTRY TODAY
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US ON THIS FIRST
MEETING OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE AND TO BRING
THIS TOPIC FORWARD OUR FIRST
SPEAKER WILL BE A MISS LORI
GONZALEZ FROM THE- RING CONN
BAND OF. THE SEND YOU INTO IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT I
WAS GIVEN THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE BECAUSE EPIDEMIC IS RIGHT.
I'M. THIS EPIDEMIC AFFECTS ALL
OF INDIAN COUNTRY AS YOU SIDE.
AND NOT JUST OUR COUNTRY THIS
ENTIRE CONTINENT SOUTH AMERICA
CENTRAL AMERICA NORTH AMERICA.
WE'RE ALL AFFECTED ARM BUT. AS
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
LARGEST NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATIONS IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND IS RANKED SIXTH IN THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF CASES OF
MISSING AND MURDERED. WOMEN
INDIGENOUS WOMEN THIS IS OF THE
UTMOST IMPORTANCE. THEY BELIEVE
IN THE TWO THOUSAND FIVE CENSUS
IT WAS ESTIMATED THAT THERE ARE
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND.
NATIVE PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OVERALL IN THE US
84% OF NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE IN THEIR
LIFETIME. 84% MANY OF THESE TAX
A TAX ULTIMATELY RESULT IN
DEATH MAKING MURDER. THE THIRD
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
AMERICAN NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN.
WITH FOUR DAUGHTERS. AND SEVEN
GRANDDAUGHTERS THIS BRINGS ME.
FRIGHTENS ME. IT IS A COUNCIL
WOMAN. WHO REPRESENTS MY TRIBE
THEIR HEALTH THEIR WELFARE
THEIR SECURITY. I FIND THIS
UNACCEPTABLE. MOST OF THESE
CRIMES ARE COMMITTED BY NON
NATIVES. MANY ARE COMMITTED ON
INDIAN LAND BUT MORE AND MORE
THESE CRIMES ARE HAPPENING IN
CITIES WHERE THERE ARE LARGE
INDIGENOUS POPULATIONS. ON
RESERVATIONS INVESTIGATIONS BY
TRIBAL POLICE AND SECURITY IT
IS OFTEN HAMPERED SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THE REMOTE AREAS WE
ARE IN. LACK OF FUNDING AND
SUPPORT BY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IF I MAKE A CALL IT
MIGHT BE HOURS. BEFORE ANYONE
CUTS CAN MAKE IT OUT. THEN OFF
RESERVATION SEEKING JUSTICE.
LET ALONE ANSWERS IN A LARGER
AND I'M FAMILIAR SYSTEM WHICH
IS ALREADY OVER TAXED LEADS TO.
DEBT AND SOMETIMES FOR PEOPLE
AND COLD CASES. I KNOW THIS
PERSONALLY I HAVE ONE DAUGHTER
WHO RAN AWAY. AND SHE WAS
MISSING FOR CLOSE TO A YEAR. I
WAS LIVING ON THE RESERVATION I
CALLED THE POLICE SHE'S FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD AND THEY SAID SHE
HADN'T BEEN GONE LONG ENOUGH.
FOR THEM TO CONSIDER HER
RUNAWAY. THANK GOD I GOT HER
BACK AND I GOT HER BACK IN ONE
PIECE NOT EMOTIONALLY BUT I GOT
HER BACK. SHE HAD BEEN OUT OF
STATE FOR MOST OF THAT TIME.
WHEN SHE LEFT THE STATE SHE
DISAPPEARED I'M SO BLESSED TO
HAVE GOTTEN ABOUT. IN SAN DIEGO
NORTH COUNTY WHERE MY
RESERVATION IS LOCATED ABOVE US
IS LAW HOW YOUR RESERVATION
THEY HAVE STARTED A GRASS ROOTS.
SUPPORT SYSTEM FOR WOMEN CALLED
THE OF ALLOCATE PROGRAM. IT
ADDRESSES SAFETY FOR NATIVE
WOMEN AND THEY HAVE AN ANNUAL
WALK TO BRING AWARENESS TO THIS
GROWING VIOLENT EPIDEMIC. IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN WHEN I FIRST
WAS ELECTED TO COUNCIL. WE WERE
HOSTING THAT WALK I'D NEVER
HEARD OF IT BEFORE. RAISING SIX
KIDS I WAS BUSY WITH OTHER
THINGS BUT I WENT AND BEFORE I
WENT I DID SOME RESEARCH. ABOUT
THE VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN I
WAS HORRIFIED THEY PARTICIPATED
IN THE WALK. HOPING IT WOULD
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. WELL IT'S
TEN YEARS LATER. THE PROBLEM IS
GROWING. I AM ALMOST SIXTY FOUR
YEARS OLD AND I'M STILL WALKING.
I AM VERY HOPEFUL. THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WILL STAND UP FOR OUR
WOMEN AND CHILDREN. ASKING FOR
YOUR ASSISTANCE. IN MAKING
THEIR SAFETY A PRIORITY HOW DO
WE DO THAT. GIVING A VOICE TO
THE MISSING. GIVE JUSTICE TO
THE MURDERED. GIVE SOLUTIONS TO
STOP VICTIMIZATION. OUR WOMEN
NEED TO HEAR. I KNOW THAT THEY
ARE NOT LESS THAN. A STRESS
AGAIN 84% AND I LOOK AT THESE
BEAUTIFUL YOUNG WOMEN SITTING
NEXT TO ME. IF WE MEET AGAIN
NEXT YEAR. THERE'S NO GUARANTEE
THEY'LL STILL BE HERE. WE HAVE
TO TAKE CARE OF THIS PROBLEM. I
KNOW THAT. AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
THREE HAS BEEN AMENDED TWICE M.
YOU KNOW I LOVE THE IDEA OF A
TASK FORCE I REALLY DO WE HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT SOLUTIONS AND THE
MORE PEOPLE THAT CAN CONTRIBUTE
IDEAS. BUT FROM WHAT I READ.
YOU KNOW THE PROPOSED THERE THE
GOAL IS TO GET A REPORT
PREPARED BY. TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
I THINK THAT REALLY IS. WITH
HOW GOVERNMENT RUNS AND ALL THE
EFFORTS THAT HAVE TO GO INTO
THIS IT IS REALISTIC. BUT IN
THE MEANTIME THE CASUALTIES ARE
PILING UP THE BODIES. ARE
PILING UP. AND FOR PARENTS.
GRANDPARENTS AUNTS AND UNCLES
WHO GRIEVE WHO WHOSE CHILDREN
HAVE BECOME PART OF THE
INVISIBLE. IT'S TOO LONG. BUT I
DO APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE. BECAUSE EVERY LIFE
MATTERS. IN OUR NATIVE CULTURE
ALL WOMEN ARE SACRED WE HAVE A
LIFE GIVERS. WHERE WERE THE A
PROTECTION. SO HELP PROTECT OUR
LIFE GIVERS. HERE IN CALIFORNIA
I AM SO PROUD TO BE AN AMERICAN
I'M SO PROUD TO BE CALIFORNIANS.
I BRAG ABOUT IT BECAUSE WE'RE
PROGRESSIVE STATE AND WE'RE A
STATE THAT CARES ABOUT OUR
POPULATION. I HOPE THIS
CONTINUES. WHILE WE'RE WAITING
TO MEET I HEARD IT'S BEEN SUCH
A LONG WHILE SINCE WE'VE HAD
THIS AND I AM SO GRATEFUL TO
YOU CHAIRMAN RAMOSE. FOR
RESURRECTING THIS. BUT LET'S
MAKE SURE WE KEEP GOING FORWARD
KEEP THE BALL ROLLING. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND COMMENTS OUR
NEXT SPEAKER WILL BE A MIS
DESTINY DURO. HELLO ONE TO COME
TALK TODAY ABOUT EPIDEMIC
THAT'S BEEN CLOUDING OUR PEOPLE
FOR MANY DECADES. BUT NOW IT'S
ONLY COME INTO ATTENTION
BECAUSE YOU HAVE GIVEN US THIS
POP FORM THANKFULLY. GIRLS AND
WOMEN ARE GOING MISSING AND
MURDERED ALARMING RATES URBAN
INDIAN HEALTH INSTITUTION DID A
SURVEY OF SEVENTY ONE CITIES
DISCOVER DIAL THE CITY'S FIVE
HUNDRED SIX CASES FELL UNDER.
THE STATUS A MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT WERE CASES
FILED UNDER MISSING TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY WERE CASES FILED AS
MURDERED. AND NINETY EIGHT
CASES HAD UNKNOWN STATUS. THE
MEDIAN AGE OF THE WOMAN IN
THESE CASES WERE TWENTY NINE. I
HATE THAT WE HAVE TO. THAT
THESE PEOPLE GOING HOME NAMES
THERE JUST NUMBERS IT'S OF
SIGNING. CRITICS THE SPEAKER.
OKAY THIS RATE AND COST OF.
THIS REPORT WAS ONLY DONE FOR
SEVENTY ONE TRIBES OF WHICH
MEANS THAT THE RATES IN CASES
CAN BE TREMENDOUSLY HIGHER THAN
MORE AND MORE ISOLATED TRIBES
WHICH IT'S MAKING IT HARDER TO
UNDERSTAND THE DEPTH OF THIS
TOPIC. ESPECIALLY WHEN NEITHER
THE FBI NOR STATE ARE WILLING
TO HELP OUR REPORT THESE CASES.
WE HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO A
WOMAN WHOSE BROTHER WAS MISSING
SHE RELATE THAT THE FBI OR THE
STATE DIDN'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT THE FBI SAID
IT WASN'T THERE JURISDICTION IN
THE STATES AT THE SAME NEITHER
ONE COMMUNICATING WITH ANOTHER.
BOTH DEPARTMENTS WERE TELLING
HER TO TELL THE OTHER BOTH
CLAIMING THEY COULD NOT HELP
GRATEFULLY SHE- KNEW HER WAY
AROUND THE LAW AND FINALLY GOT
THE FBI TO. FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO HER LEFT ONE WELL
IT MIGHT HAVE NOT BEEN A WOMAN
THIS IS THE TROUBLES NATIVE
FAMILIES FACE WHEN REPORTING A
CRIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THERE AND I SPEAK WILL
BE AND A BALLOT FOR NOW. THE
TROUBLES IN THESE SITUATIONS
THAT NAY THE FAMILIES FACE A
SHOULD BE HANDLED PROPERLY BY
THE FBI. REPORTING LOVED ONES
MISSING THEY SHOULD HAVE NOT
GOTTEN TO THE POINT THE FBI
SHOULD HAVE HANDLED THIS
PROPERLY FROM THE BEGINNING
BECAUSE NOT NOT EVERY FAMILY
KNOWS WHO TO CALL. AND THE
PEOPLE THAT SHOULD BE HELPING
YOU DON'T. AND NO FAMILY SHOULD
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE STRESS OF
THAT THEY'RE ALREADY MOURNING
THE LOSS OF THEIR LOVED ONES
AND NOW THEY HAVE. TO GO
THROUGH MORE PAIN WHILE DEALING
WITH THE FACT THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS NOT. GOING TO
HELP THEM. THAT THEY MUST. THAT
THEY MUST DEAL WITH IT
THEMSELVES THIS IS STRAIGHT OUT
AND HUMANE TO TELL SOMEONE THIS
IS NOT OUR JURISDICTION WE CAN
DO ANYTHING ONE ACTUALLY IS
THEIR JURISDICTIONS AND THEY
SHOULD DO SOMETHING BECAUSE WE
ARE PEOPLE OF THE US AND OUR
RIGHTS AS PEOPLE ARE THE SAME
AS ANYONE ELSE'S. WE PLAYED
WITH THEIR LISTEN TO US OUR
SISTERS ARE BEING TAKEN AND
KILLED AND NO ONE IS TURNING IN
HI. IF IT WAS HAPPENING IN YOUR
COMMUNITY OR TO YOUR RICH
RELATIVE. HOW WOULD YOU FEEL
WHEN THE COPS SAY THEY WILL NOT
HELP YOU. WHEN YOU'RE LOST IN
PAIN. FEELING CONFUSED AND
BETRAYED THINK ABOUT THAT. NO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
ANNABELLA HERNANDEZ RAVEN COST
US AND DESTINY DURO. BRING IN
THE MESSAGE FULL CIRCLE THAT
IT'S A IT'S A TOPIC THAT'S
FACING INDIAN COUNTRY OVER THE
YEARS BUT IS DEEPLY AFFECTING
OUR OUR YOUNGER FEMALE MEMBERS
I'M INNER SO THANK YOU FOR
COMING FORWARD I THANK YOU
LAURIE FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN
BRINGING THIS ISSUE. UP. TO THE
FOREFRONT ADVOCACY THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD WE DO
HAVE SOME. WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
IN THE LEGISLATURE WE DID MOVE
FORWARD A RESOLUTION THAT
CAUGHT ON MAY AS MISSING AMER
INDIGENOUS WOMEN MONTH WHICH
WILL BE REOCCURRING. WE ALSO
HAVE A RESOLUTION JOINT
RESOLUTION JOINT RESOLUTION
SEVENTEEN. THAT CALLS ON THE
STATE TO START TO COLLECT DATA.
ON THE MISSING HAMMER
INDIGENOUS WOMEN IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHICH THROUGH THE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S NUMBER SIX YES ON
THE LIST AND THAT IS STILL
MAKING ITS WAY THROUGH THE
PROCESS. BUT BRINGING. THESE
ADVOCACY IN THE TEST WAS UP FOR
LEGISLATORS TO HEAR ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE. IT IS VITAL
AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
MESSAGE CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD THAT IS NOT JUST
SOMETHING THAT'S THAT'S
HAPPENING NOW IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON AND WE
FIND THE ARE GETTING. TRACTION
ON THE ADVOCACY IN THE VOICE TO
GET SOME TYPE OF MOVEMENT
CIRCLE AROUND AND BRING IN
RESOLVE TO THIS ON
JURISDICTIONAL DIVIDES WHO HAS
THE INVESTIGATIVE A THORNY ON
THEIR- RIGHT THOSE TYPES OF
ISSUES THAT NOW WE CAN GO BACK
AND START TO. LOOK AT IS THERE
ANY. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I ALSO WANNA THANK
YOU FOR. A SEVEN IS COMMITTEE
AND BRING US STUFF FOR THIS
ISSUE. I SUPPORT A. B. SIXTEEN
FIFTY THREE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER. WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISHED OF THE
MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS. WOMAN TASK FORCE
THIS TASK FORCE WITH THIS CLUB
LAYERED COLLABORATED. WITH
CALIFORNIA'S INDIAN TRIBES TO
ENSURE RESOURCES. ARE USED
EFFECTIVELY TO INVESTIGATE
CASES OF MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS PERSONS IN THE
STATE. THIS BILL WAS HELD IN
COMMITTEE WHICH IS UNFORTUNATE.
FOR MISS GONZALEZ. I'D LIKE TO
ASK YOU WHAT ABOUT BETTER
INTERAGENCY COOPERATION. EVEN
IDEAS ON HOW WE CAN ACCOMPLISH
THIS GOAL. I'M I THINK WE NEED
TO KEEP PUBLICIZING IT YOU TURN
THE HEAT UP ON SOMETHING YOU
GET RESULTS IT COMES TO A BOIL.
WE KEEP DOING THAT THE GRASS
ROOTS ORGANIZATIONS NGUYEN WE
NEED YOUR HELP AND WILL WORK
WITH YOU. IN FACT I DID LEAVE
JUST SO YOU KNOW I LEFT COPIES
OF THIS REPORT WITH YOUR
OFFICE. BUT IT'S BEEN UPDATED
IN JULY. I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT FOR NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN.
OUR MURDER RATE IS TEN TIMES
THAT OF THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
AND THE AGE IS. AVERAGING JUST
TWENTY FOUR THEY'RE KIND OF
INFORMATION WE KEEP GETTING IT
OUT THAT OUT THERE. IT'S GOING
TO SPUR SPUR THOSE AGENCIES
FORWARD WE'VE GOT TO WORK
TOGETHER. AND I WOULD SAY WITH
OUR OF THE LOCAL WALK THAT WE
DO A VALID CAM MEANING
BUTTERFLY IN MY LANGUAGE. IT'S
GROWING AND I'M SEEING MORE
TRIBAL LEADERS THERE. CHAIRMAN
BRINGING THEIR FAMILIES THEIR
YOUNG DAUGHTERS BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO MAKE THEM AWARE. COM I'D
LOVE TO SEE ALL OF YOU THERE.
PUT ON YOUR WALKING SHOES. I'M
SIXTY ALMOST SIXTY FOUR. I WANT
YOU TO KEEP UP WITH ME ARE YOU
DON'T LOOK AT. IT IN A MORE
IMPORTANTLY HAS CALIFORNIA
PROVIDE TRIBAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITH BETTER TRAINING
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES THAT'S
REALLY BIG ISSUE I'LL BE HONEST
WITH YOU THINK ABOUT HOMICIDES
IT'S THE WAY YOU GET BETTER AT
INVESTIGATING HOMICIDES BY
GETTING THE REPS AND. YOU KNOW
COMING FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
MORE YOU INVESTIGATE. THE MORE
DEPTH CHART IT'S SOLVING THESE
CASES AND IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
MISSING PERSON CASES ARE VERY
TOUGH CASES I WAS A SPOKESMAN
FOR FOUR YEARS THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT SO. WE LAW CASES
DURING THAT TIME AND TO BE
HONEST THERE'S THERE MISSED
GIVES A VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE-
LESSER EXTINGUISHED
CIRCUMSTANCES LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS NOT LUNCH A SEARCH FOR
ANYBODY OBVIOUSLY THAT. DRAWS A
LOT OF RESOURCES WAS REALLY
TOUGH TO DEAL WITH SO HOW CAN
WE BETTER. HELP TRAIN OF FOLKS
IN INDIAN COUNTRY TO DEAL WITH
THESE CASES. AND HAVE A VESTED
IN. I THINK THAT THE- LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES NEED TO
WORK WITH THE TRIBAL SECURITIES
WE ARE A APPEAL TO EIGHTY STATE
I KNOW THAT FOR MY TRIBE. WE'RE
BLESSED WITH GAMING AND SO WE
PAY FOR TWO ADDITIONAL. THE
SHERIFF'S FOR OUR AREA BECAUSE
WORLD I MEAN LET'S FACE IT MOST
RESERVATIONS. AROUND AM IN THE
BERNESE RIGHT WHERE I LIVE. IT
ARE THE CLOSEST TOWN IS THE
UNINCORPORATED TOWN OF VALLEY
CENTER THE SHERIFF'S STATION
SHUTS DOWN. IN THE IT'S CLOSED
IN THE EVENING SO WHEN YOU CALL
NINE ONE ONE IN YOUR GETTING AN
OFFICE IN SAN DIEGO. WELL
THAT'S A LONG WAY OFF. SO I
THINK WE'VE GOT TO HAVE MORE
MONEY FOR MORE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NUMBER ONE AND THEN NUMBER TWO
TO WORK WITH THE TRIBES RIGHT
NOW OUR OUR TRIBAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS OBSERVING REPORT.
BUT WE NEED MORE TRAINING SO WE
CAN BE MORE EFFECTIVE OURSELVES.
AND THAT MEANS WORKING WITH THE
US LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU A SO MEMBER
COOPER AS SOMETHING WOMAN COULD
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND I JUST WANNA.
SAY TO DESTINY RAVEN AND
ANNABELLA THAT YOUR VOICES ARE
SO CRITICAL AND IMPORTANT TO
COME HERE TO THE STATE CAPITOL
TO THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE. AND TO
HAVE YOUR TESTIMONY BE PART OF
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT ONLY
INCREDIBLY HISTORIC AND HASN'T
BEEN DONE BEFORE BUT YOU'RE
SETTING THE TONE AND PRESIDENT
OF WHAT. THE SELECT COMMITTEE
CAN DO AND HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD TO ENSURING THAT THE
VOICES OF INDIGENOUS NATIVE
WOMEN ARE HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CAPITOL IN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. PRIOR TO JOINING
THE LEGISLATURE I WAS THERE
LAST. DURING THE RISE OF
ATROCITIES ACROSS INDIGENOUS
NATIVE WOMEN TO YOUR
APPOINTMENTS GONZALEZ
THROUGHOUT THE AMERICAS
THROUGHOUT CANADA THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES THE BORDERS
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES. AND
LATIN AMERICA AS A WOMAN THAT
IDENTIFIES AS AN INDIGENOUS
WOMAN MYSELF. I FIND IT I FIND
MYSELF TO BE IN A IN A
SITUATION OUR HOW CAN WE NEED
TO MORE. SO I AM THE CHAIRWOMAN
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
GIRLS AND WOMEN OF COLOR ACROSS
THE ACROSS THE STATE AND I
WOULD INVITE YOU TO DO THE SAME
PRESENTATION ONLY FIGURE OUT
WHEN WE MOVE FORWARD TO OUR OUR
NEXT OUR OUR FIRST HEARING
WHICH IS ALSO A COMMITTEE
THAT'S BEEN RESURRECTED. ON THE
STATUS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
WOMEN IN INDIGENOUS INDIGENOUS
A NATIVE WOMEN ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND. THE
BORDERS THAT WE KNOW NOW. BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
YOU'RE HERE I THINK YOUR
TESTIMONY IS CRITICAL AND I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE THAT AS
WE- TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE
DO. THEY CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE.
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO COME THE
YOU CONTINUE TO TELL YOUR STORY.
I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT PERHAPS
THAT THIS IS ONLY HAPPENING IN
INDIAN COUNTRY IS NOT ENTIRELY
ACCURATE I REPRESENT THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES AND SO I'VE BEEN
HEARING YOUR TESTIMONY AND
THINKING HOW CAN I WORK WITH MY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT FOR LA
COUNTY TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING AS TO THE
SENSITIVITY AND CULTURAL
AWARENESS THAT NEEDS TO TAKE
PLACE WHEN IT COMES TO
IDENTIFYING. INDIGENOUS A
NATIVE AMERICAN CRIMES
ESPECIALLY TO WOMEN WITHIN OUR
OWN REGION AND HOW DO WE GET
THE LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OR THE
LA LA COUNTY COMMISSION ON
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS ALSO
ENGAGED AND INVOLVED THANK YOU
FOR COMING HERE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE ALLIES THROUGHOUT
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA UP.
WANTING AND WANTED TO MAKE. WE
IN THIS MOVEMENT AND BRING IT
TO LIGHT IN A MUCH BROADER
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY WOMAN CARDIO ANY
OTHER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
JUST A CLARIFYING QUESTION FOR
ACCOUNTS WOMAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
YOUNG WOMEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING PART OF THIS PROCESS. YOU
MENTIONED THE OF VALIDA IS THAT
THEY SAY THAT QUICKLY THOUGH I
CAN GUESS ABOUT LOOK AT WHEN
I'M I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH. THE
NAME KEY TYPES WILL BE MORE
ABOUT AYE. AYES WHAT IT DOESN'T.
BETTER CLIENT IT'S A GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS PUT
TOGETHER ON. YOUR RESERVATION.
AND IT CAME ABOUT A BROWN THE
SAME TIME AS WE BECAME OF WHERE
OF ALL WHY YOU KNOW VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN ACT. I AS- AN
EDUCATIONAL TOOL IN A SUPPORT
TOOL FOR WOMEN WHO WERE
EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
BUT NOW WE KNOWN. IT'S BEEN SO
LONG THAT LEADS TO. WOMEN WHO
ARE MISSING AND MURDERED STILL
THEY SUPPORT ARM. ADVOCACY THEY
THEY HELP IF SOMEBODY DOESN'T
HAVE A VOICE THE HELP HIM FIND
IT. THERE'S TRAINING FOR PEOPLE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PUT UP WITH THIS. IT'S
AN IT'S A WAY OF LIFE. MAYBE
THEY GREW UP WITH BUT THE TO
BREAK THE CYCLE. AND IT BRINGS
US ALL TOGETHER AT LEAST IN
THAT AREA BECAUSE WE HAVE
SEVERAL RESERVATIONS BRINGS US
TOGETHER AND WE CAN START THE
CONVERSATION LIKE WE'RE DOING
HERE. BUT ON A MUCH SMALLER
SCALE. TO HELP LIFT UP IN OUR
ONE ANOTHER. AND BE GOOD
EXAMPLES TO OUR YOUNG WOMEN WHO
ARE OUR FUTURE. SO THIS IS A
STAND ALONE NONPROFIT OR TO
PROGRAM OF THE HIGHWAY INDIANS.
IT'S A NONPROFIT NOW. AND BUT
LOWER YOUR RESERVATION AND. IS
KIND OF WHERE THEIR THEIR
HEADQUARTERS WITH THE LOCATED
YEAH AND IS IT A V. L. I CA
IT'S A V. E. L. L. WHERE I
WROTE IT DOWN HERE. HE QUE ES
DE QUE I'M GLAD I ASKED OKAY
I'M DOWN THERE ON FACEBOOK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. BROAD
KNOWLEDGE THE DITION OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
THANK YOU WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT'S
FACING INDIAN COUNTRY HAS BEEN
FACING ANY COUNTRY FOR MANY
YEARS THE MISSING EMERGING AS
WOMEN. WE DID THIS LEGISLATURE
DID MOVE FORWARD AND
RECOGNIZING MAY AS MISNOMER
INDIGENOUS WOMEN'S MONTH THAT
WILL BE REOCCURRING WE ALSO DO
HAVE ANOTHER RESOLUTION
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
SEVENTEEN IT'S WORKING ITS WAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND IT'S
HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
GET THAT.MOVING FORWARD ON TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR THIS YEAR TO
CONTINUE THE ADVOCACY THERE.
AND WITHOUT ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON A
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND THE IMPORTANCE AND DISTRESS
TO SEE THE IMPORTANCIA IN
INDIAN COUNTRY THIS NEEDED TO
ADVOCACY THAT'S THERE. AND TO
HIGHLIGHT THE YOUNG MEMBERS
COMING FORWARD TO ENSURING THAT
THIS IS A TOPIC THAT FACES
INDIAN COUNTRY AT ALL LEVELS.
IN ALL AGE GROUPS WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OUR NEXT. PANEL
UNDER THE ISSUES IMPACTING
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN TRIBES IS
THE STATUS OF TRAVEL YOUTH
DIVERSION PROGRAMS AND WITH US
TODAY AND WILL BE SPEAKING TO
THIS TOPIC WILL BE DEVON LLAMA
ESTABA CHIEF JUDGE OF INTER
TRIBAL COURT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND MISS TEMAS ALE
NO MY **** FROM THE IT BY
NATION OF SANTA IS ABOUT. HOW
CAN A GOOD MORNING ASK FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE FOR THOSE YOU THAT
HER TO SPEAK THIS MORNING WILL
BE A LITTLE BIT REPETITIVE BUT
WITH ALL THESE WONDERFUL
SPEAKERS BEFORE US WE HAVE
SOMETHING TO ADD IN AND LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS. GET MY NAME'S IVANA
MAIS Và I'M FROM THE NATION OF
SANTA ISABEL I AM CURRENTLY THE
CHIEF JUDGE OF THE INTER TRIBAL
COURT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
LOCATED IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. WE
SERVE OVER A DOZEN FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND A HANDFUL
OF OTHER TRIBES AND INDIAN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT USE THIS ON
SUBJECT MATTER BASIS. ON. I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT THE STATE OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA'S INDIAN COUNTRY AND
AGAIN WHEN I THINK. ASSEMBLYMAN
RAMOS AND THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON NATIVE AMERICAN. AFFAIRS FOR
BEING HERE AND FOR THE
LEADERSHIP YOU'RE SHOWING IN
SUPPORTING. THE VITAL PROGRAMS
FOR JUVENILE JUSTICE. AND THAT
ARE STILL NEEDED IN INDIAN
COUNTRY. ON THE U. THREE
INVESTMENT GRANT TRIBAL YOUTH
DIVERSION PROGRAM IS A
WONDERFUL ADDITION. TO THE
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
NECESSARY. TO ADDRESS THESE
ONGOING ISSUES IN JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND WE'RE SO VERY
EXCITED AS THE COURT TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THAT AND SUPPORT THE
OTHER TRIBAL COURTS IN THE
STATE. ON THAT ARE LOOKING TO
BE ABLE TO. BENEFIT FROM THE
SUPPORT THAT THAT WILL BRING TO
THE STATE AND TO OUR TRIED. ON
THE NEED FOR ACTION IN
ADDRESSING THE ENDEMIC ISSUES
FACING THE NATIVE YOUTH OF
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT NEW AND THEY
IN FACT HAVE EXISTED FOR
HUNDREDS OF YEARS OF THE
HISTORY OF THE AMERICAN INDIAN
IS NOT A KNOWN HOWEVER OFTEN
IGNORED IGNORED BY OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND OUR OWN NATIVE PEOPLE AND
THE EFFECTS OF THAT ARE REAL
PAIN AND REAL ISSUES AND IF WE
DO NOTHING. IF WE STAND BY WE
ARE PERPETUAL THE LOSS OF OUR
NATIVE YOUTH WHO ARE THE FUTURE
LEADERS OF OUR TRIBAL NATIONS
ON MANY PEOPLE MAKE THAT
STATEMENT BUT FOR US WITH OUR
TRIBAL NATIONS IN SUCH LOW
NUMBERS IT IT IS IN FACT THE
TRUTH THAT YOU THEY ARE OUR
FUTURE LEADERS AND THEY ARE THE
ONES. THAT WE NEED TO COME BACK
AT. IN OUR COMMUNITY TO OFFER
EVERYTHING THE GOVERNMENT'S
OFFER WE NEED ARE USED TO BE
EDUCATED WHETHER IT'S IN THE
TRADITIONAL WESTERN EDUCATION
SYSTEM. AND THEY BECOME
PROFESSIONALS OR WHETHER
THEY'RE EDUCATION IS IN THE
CULTURAL SENSE IN THE MEDICINAL
SENSE OF THE WAYS THAT THAT
WE'VE LIVED AS NATIVE PEOPLE
FOR SO LONG. SO WE NEED THEM TO
BE LEADERS AND ALL OF THESE
AREAS AND THEY CAN'T DO THAT.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS TO
SUCCEED AND HAVING PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS IS GOING TO. LIFT UP
THE YOUTH THAT ARE AND SO SUCH
A POSITION THAT THEY FIND
THEMSELVES ON NEEDING THAT HELP
AND NOT THE PUNISHMENT. ON
GROWING UP I WAS EXPOSED TO
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
NATIVE YOUTH WERE AND I
CONSIDER MYSELF VERY LUCKY I
CAME FROM A FAMILY THAT HAD
LOTS A LOVE AND CARED FOR US
BUT THERE WERE ALSO ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT SURROUNDED US THAT
WE CAN EITHER YOU CAN EITHER
GET OUT YOU CAN'T BEAT THEM
JOIN THEM. AND. YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY LOOKING BACK THERE
WERE MANY THINGS I WAS EXPOSED
TO AND MY FAMILY MEMBERS
INCLUDING THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THE JUVENILE
DELINQUENCY PREMATURE DEATH
AMONG OUR FAMILY MEMBERS AND
OTHER THINGS THAT I GREW UP
WITH NOT REALIZING HOW AND
HEALTHY THEY WERE. AND MAKING A
POINT IN MY OWN FAMILY IN MY
OWN COMMUNITIES TO SEE THAT WE
DO SOMETHING WE SEE THAT AND WE
DON'T IDLY SIT BY. THE THINGS
THAT. WE'VE GROWN UP WITH ALSO
INCLUDING THE INHERENT RACISM
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND GOVERNMENTS
THAT COME THROUGH SOMETIMES
SUBTLY SUCH AS CULTURALLY IN IT
IN A SENSITIVE EVENTS THE
MAKING MISSIONS OUT OF SUGAR
CUBES THINGS LIKE THAT THAT
LOWER THE SELF ESTEEM OF OUR
NATIVE YOUTH THE HOMEWORK
ASSIGNMENTS THAT HAVE PICTURES
OF CARTOON LIKE NATIVES THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT CONSTANTLY.
MAKE OUR NATIVE CHILDREN FEEL
LIKE THEIR LESSER THAN THEY ARE
AND THAT THEY HAVE A HISTORY
THAT'S NOT IMPORTANT.
COMPLAINING TO THE SCHOOL AND
THEN I HAVE TO ADMIT I GO TO
THE SCHOOL PROBABLY A LITTLE
BIT MORE OFTEN THAN SOME
PARENTS IT MAY SEEM TRIVIAL.
BUT AS THE AS THE NATIVE YOUTH
GOING UP IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEMS I WENT TO OVER SEVEN
SCHOOLS GROWING UP WE MOVED WAY
TOO MUCH. THOSE THINGS ADD UP
AND WHEN YOU SEE THOSE THINGS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN ON YOU
BEGIN TO BE CONFUSED ABOUT YOUR
HISTORY AND YOU BEGIN TO
BELIEVE THEM. THOSE TYPES OF.
UP PRACTICES AND CURRICULUM.
LEAD TO LOW SELF ESTEEM. WHICH
LEADS TO PEOPLE BEING ANGRY AND
VIOLENT. WHICH LEADS TO
DESPERATION AND DEPRESSION. AND
THEN DRUG ABUSE AND EVENTUALLY
YOU SEE YOURSELF IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
THEN EVENTUALLY TO PRESENT. ON.
AND THAT'S JUST A PATH THAT
WE'VE ALL SEEN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ALL TOO OFTEN AND
THAT THIS IS A WAY TO PREVENT
THAT FROM THE BEGINNING TO GET
IN THERE THE FIRST TIME THAT
THAT KID. GOES AND TAX AT THE
TRAVEL OFFICE MAYBE THEY'RE
ONLY TEN YEARS OLD SAY THEY'RE
JUST KIDS BEING KIDS WELL YEAH
SOMETIMES BUT THAT TEN YEAR OLD
WAS ALSO MY BROTHER. WHO
DECIDED IT WOULD BE FINE AT TEN
YEARS OLD TO GO TAG AT THE
MIDDLE SCHOOL. ON AND HE WAS
ARRESTED AT TEN YEARS OLD. BACK
THEN. IN IN THE MID EIGHTIES. I
WAS NO EXPERT ON JUVENILE
JUSTICE THEN BUT I DO KNOW
THAT. THERE WASN'T A DIVERSION
PROGRAM THAT THEY SENT THEM TO
THEY ARRESTED THEM AND THE COPS
CAME KNOCKED ON THE DOOR BUT
THE KID. ON THERE WAS CERTAINLY
NO NATIVE DIVERSION PROGRAMS
AND SO. AND THAT LED MY BROTHER
ON THE PATH THEY JUST
PREVIOUSLY EXPLAINED. ON AND MY
BROTHER AND FORTUNATELY WAS IN
A CAR ACCIDENT TO ADD DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE AT THE AGE
OF TWENTY FIVE. AND WHILE
DURING HIS LIFETIME HE HE DID A
LOT FOR THE TWENTY FIVE YEARS
THAT HE WAS HERE HE WAS A GREAT
ADVOCATE FOR NATIVE LANGUAGE A
VIOLATION REVITALIZATION
PROGRAMS HE WAS GREAT YOUNG
PLAYER WHICH IS OUR TRADITIONAL
NATIVE HAND GAME AND HE TAUGHT
MANY MANY OF OUR YOUTH. ON OUR
RESERVATION AND BEYOND. ON BUT
BUT THOSE THOSE
INTERGENERATIONAL SICKNESSES
THAT FOLLOW US ARE THINGS THAT
YOU CAN HAVE ALL THE LOVE AND
YOU CAN HAVE ALL THE CULTURE.
BUT IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
SYSTEM TO ALSO EMBRACE AND
SUPPORT THAT. IN THAT SYSTEM
RIPS YOU AWAY FROM THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE POSITIVE. YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO FIND YOURSELF ANYWHERE
BUT WHERE HE UNFORTUNATELY DID.
ON AND I SEE THESE YOUTH EVERY
WEEK COME THROUGH MY COURT I
STILL AM A PRACTICING INDIAN
LAW ATTORNEY AND I DO A LOT OF
CHILD ABUSE CASES AND I SEE
THESE KIDS COME IN AND I JUST
SEE THE FACES OF SO MANY BEFORE
THEM AND I KNOW WHERE THEY'RE
HEADED. IF WE DON'T SOMETHING.
ON UNFORTUNATELY THE SYSTEMS
THAT WE WORK IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AS WELL. AS THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM ARE NOT
EQUIPPED. AND CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW WE CAN'T EXPECT THEM TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE WHAT THE TRIBE
COULD PROVIDE. AND THAT'S WHY
WE NEED THE TRIBAL PROGRAMS
BECAUSE THE TRIBE KNOWS IT'S
COMMUNITY. THE TRIBE KNOWS THE
CULTURE AND WE HAVE THE TOOLS
THAT ARE BEST SUITED FOR ARE
YOU. RIGHT NOW THERE'S MANY
MANY TRIBAL COURTS IN THE STATE
THAT ARE EMBARKING ON
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAMS
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN. ON
IT'S NOT NEW BUT IT CERTAINLY
TAKING OFF MORE AND MORE YOU
SEE MANY HIGH SCHOOLS PUTTING
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAMS
TOGETHER WHERE KIDS DON'T GET
AUTOMATICALLY SUSPENDED OR
EXPELLED ANYMORE THERE'S
ACTUALLY WHAT WE WOULD CALL A
TALKING CIRCLE OR A PEACEMAKING
GROUP. FOR EVERYBODY SITS IN A
CIRCLE IT'S NOT DIFFICULT AND
IT'S WAY CHEAPER. COME IN AND
JUST TO BRING THE PARENTS AND
THE PRINCIPAL EVERYBODY HAS TO
LOOK AT EACH OTHER AND TALK
ABOUT WHY THEY DID THIS AND I
SAW THIS EXAMPLE OF THESE TWO
GIRLS. THAT JUST YOU KNOW. AT
LEAST THOUGHT THEY HATED EACH
OTHER WALKING BY CURSE WORDS
EVEN SHE GOT INTO FIGHTS. AND
WHEN THEY FINALLY SIT DOWN THE
CIVIL HOW DID YOU GUYS LIKE
EACH OTHER WELL I HEARD SHE
CALLED ME A NAME. AND THAT WAS
REALLY ALL IT WAS. AND BY THE
END OF THEIR THEIR YOU KNOW
TALKING CIRCLE TYPE PROCESS THE
GIRLS WERE LIKE THIS IS THIS IS
STUPID WHAT WHAT ARE WE DOING.
ON AND THEY WERE ABLE TO JUST
PUT THEIR DIFFERENCES ASIDE
MAYBE THEY'RE NOT BEST FRIENDS
BUT THEY CAN CO EXIST AT SCHOOL
WITHOUT THOSE TYPES OF.
INTERFERENCES AND THAT'S EXACT
TYPE THINGS WE WANT TO DO. ON
ONE OF THE COUNCIL MEMBERS FROM
ONE OF THE TRIBES THAT'S
INTERESTED IN THE PILOT THAT
THE INTER TRIBAL COURT IS
PUTTING TOGETHER. SHARE THIS
STORY WITH ME. ON IN THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE SADLY
THERE'S A LOT OF FIGHTING ALSO.
INFIGHTING BETWEEN THE NATIVE
STUDENTS AND A LOT OF THAT GOES
BACK TO THEIR OWN IDENTITY. IT
GOES BACK TO HAVING TO LOOK A
CERTAIN WAY IS A NATIVE PERSON
AND MAYBE NOT LOOKING THAT WAY.
ON YOUR TO LIGHT YOUR TOO DARK
WELL YOUR PARENTS ARE ARE
MEXICAN AMERICAN KNOW YOUR
PARENTS ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN.
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. ARE
THINGS THAT WE AS TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES TRIBAL LEADERS NEED
TO STOP. AND THAT WE NEED TO
EMBRACE ALL OF OUR OUR NATIVE
YOUTH AND IN ALL OF OUR YOU. SO
THESE GIRLS HAD THAT SAME KIND
OF A SITUATION. AND THEY GOT IN
A REALLY BAD FIGHT AT SCHOOL
SAID THEY CALLED IN THE PARENTS.
AND WHEN EVERYBODY GOT THEIR
THE PARENTS WERE LIKE. WHAT DO
YOU GUYS DOING HERE WHAT ARE
YOU DOING HERE THEY THEIR
FAMILY. THE GIRLS HAD NO IDEA
THEY WERE FAMILY. ON AND SO
WHAT THE TRIBE DID. AS THEY
SAID YOU KNOW WHAT WHEN THIS
COMES UP WE'RE GONNA MAKE ALL
OF OUR YOUTH. ON. SIT DOWN AND
LOOK AT THEIR FAMILY TREE AND
THEY BRING IN THE ENROLLMENT
DEPARTMENT REPRESENTATIVE AND
THEY SIT DOWN AND THEY SAY
YOU'RE GOING TO FILL OUT YOUR
FAMILY TREE AND THEY ALL FIND
OUT OH MY GOSH I'M RELATED TO
HER AND RELATED TO HIM AND
THAT'S A GOOD. THING TO KNOW
FOR OTHER REASONS. SO. IT IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHERE
YOU COME FROM. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE VERY VERY SMALL
AND I TELL MY OWN CHILDREN YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE COUSINS ON PRETTY
MUCH EVERY RESERVATION IN SAN
DIEGO SO JUST REMEMBER THAT.
AND KNOW WHO YOUR FAMILY IS AND
SO THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
PRACTICAL THINGS BUT THINGS
THAT THAT COME FROM JUST. THAT
THE ESSENCE OF BEING WHO WE ARE
THEY CAN DO SO MUCH TO PREVENT
THE PATH THAT WE SEE SO MANY OF
OUR YOUTH. GOING DOWN. RIGHT
NOW THE INTER TRIBAL COURT IS
EMBARKING ON A HEALING TO
WELLNESS PROJECT WHERE WERE
DEVELOPING A YOUTH PEER COURT.
WE VISITED SEVERAL MODELS FROM
LA TO RIVERSIDE TO ONES THAT WE
SAW ON OTHER STATES AND WE
REALLY LIKE TO THE YOUTH CARE
COURT MODEL BECAUSE IT LETS YOU
HOLD THEIR FELLOW YOUTH
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
AND IT ALSO PROVIDES THE YOUTH
PARTICIPATING AT THE COULD SAY
THE PIER JURY ON TO LEARN ABOUT
THE COURT SYSTEM IN A WAY WHERE
IT'S NOT ADVERSARIAL WHERE
THEY'RE NOT COMING IN WHEN
THEY'RE IN TROUBLE BUT THEY'RE
THERE TO BE PROACTIVE AND TO DO
SOMETHING. TO SUPPORT THEIR
THEIR FELLOW YOU. SO WE ARE
EMBARKING ON THIS PILOT WHERE
WE HAVE ALREADY TWO TRIBES THAT
ARE INTERESTED WE HAVE SEVERAL
MORE THAT ARE ALREADY DOING
DIFFERENT TYPES OF THINGS WITH
WELLNESS PLANS WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO BRING THIS ALL
TOGETHER SO THAT NGUYEN TRIBAL
POLICE SITE. THE JUVENILES INTO
OUR COURT FOR. BASICALLY STATUS
OFFENSES THE LOW LEVEL OFFENSES
THAT THE COURT WILL DIVERT THEM
INTO THIS YOUTH PEER COURT
WHERE WE WILL. ESSENTIALLY
REQUIRE THEM TO ADMIT GUILT TO
BE ABLE TO ACCEPT THE WHEN I
CALL MORE PERSPECTIVE
CONSEQUENCES THEN HAVING THAT
ON THERE THEIR TRIBAL COURT
RECORD ON AND HAVING JUST
FACING LARGE FINES THAT ARE
GOING TO DO ANYTHING TO ADDRESS
THE ACTUAL PROBLEM SO WE'RE
GONNA DO THINGS SUCH AS
COMMUNITY SERVICE CULTURAL
PROGRAMS. THEY WILL ALSO HAVE
TO COME BACK AND SERVE ON THE
PIER JURY AND THAT'S A MODEL
THAT RIVERSIDE COUNTY DID THAT
I WAS VERY IMPRESSED WITH. AND
WHEN WE WERE THERE. ON SOME OF
THE KIDS THAT WERE ORIGINALLY
THE OFFENDERS AND HAD CAME BACK
YOU KNOW THEY WERE THE ONES
RIGHT UP THERE IN THE FACE OF
THE OFFENDERS ASKING QUESTIONS
AND SAYING DIDN'T YOU THINK
ABOUT YOUR COMMUNITY WHEN YOU
WERE DOING THIS. AND IT WAS
REALLY NEAT TO SEE THE TURN
AROUND IN IN THOSE YOUTH AND
I'M I'M HOPING WE CAN REPLICATE
THAT MODEL WITHIN OUR OWN. ON I
COULD TALK ALL DAY ABOUT THE
EXCITING THINGS THAT WE ARE
WANTING TO DO. I HOPE THAT I'VE
PROVIDED YOU. AND SNAPSHOT OF
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO DO AND
SOME THINGS THAT MANY OF THE
OTHER TRIBAL COURTS HAVE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DOING. BUT WE
CAN'T DO THAT WITHOUT CONTINUED
SUPPORT. AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
THE MORAL SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT AND OF
COURSE THE FUNDING. AND THE
TRIBES ARE DOING ALL AYE THEY
CAN IN IN MY COURT. TO ENSURE
THAT THEY LOOK AT EVERY
RESOURCE. BECAUSE THIS IS TRULY
FOR THE MOST IMPORTANT RESOURCE
WE HAVE AND THAT'S OUR
CHILDREN. ON A DOWN GOING TO
TURN OVER TO MY HOPE PRISONER
WHO'S GOING TO PROVIDE A YOUTH
PERSPECTIVE. HI I AM TO REALIZE
FOR A AND I'M FROM THE SENATE
BUT THE SENATE IS ABOUT
RESERVATIONS HAVE BEEN SAN
DIEGO BUT I'M ALSO FROM THE
NUMBER OF THE RESERVATION. AND
HOPING. AND I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU ALL FOR ALL OF YOU HAVING
ME HERE AND I HAD THIS SPEECH
PLANNED OUT BUT AS I WAS
READING IT I REALIZED. MUCH
MORE ISSUES THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN SAID AND I NOTICED A LOT
OF YOU WERE ASKING HOW TO HELP
AND HOW. YOU GUYS CAN TAKE
PART. BUT THE TRUTH IS THAT
NATIVES KNOW EACH OTHER BETTER
THAN ANYONE WE CAN HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES BETTER THAN. ANY
NON NATIVE CAN EVER AND IT'S.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT AS I SAID
I'M KIND OF AN ODD BALL NATIVE
WHERE I LIVE OFF THE
RESERVATION BUT- I A GO THERE
ARE I GOT IT CULTURAL
GATHERINGS ALMOST EVERY WEEKEND
AND I'M UP THERE ALL THE TIME.
BUT I'VE NOTICED THAT THERE'S A
LACK OF MOTIVATION AMONGST ALL
MY FRIENDS AND COUSINS. THEY
FEEL AND WHAT THEY HAVE IN
THEIR LIFE RIGHT NOW IS TO
NORMAL FOR THEM WITH THE LACK
OF MONEY. THE LACK OF THE
SUPPORT FROM THEIR OWN PARENTS
YOU KNOW DRIVING YOU KNOW THEY
HAVE TO ASK PEOPLE TO DRIVE
THEM TO THEIR OWN CULTURAL
GATHERING THAT'S MAYBE THREE
MINUTES DOWN THE ROAD. AND IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
FIND MOTIVATION LIVING ON THE
RESERVATION. AS THERE'S NOT
REALLY THAT MANY PROGRAMS THAT
ARE NATIVE PEOPLE CAN THINK OF
TO HELP EACH OTHER. WE'RE SO
DIVIDED AND IT REALLY SHOWS AND
THE GATHERINGS YOU KNOW. WHEN
WE JUST HAD OUR CULTURAL
GATHERING JUST NOT A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO BUT- I'D SEE KIDS
STAYED RATHER YOU KNOW SMOKE
SOME WEED AND SAID OF TAKING
PART IN THEIR OWN CULTURE AND-
TO BE HONEST OUR CULTURE IS
WHAT WE HAVE LEFT AND WHAT
KEEPS US AS A COMMUNITY
TOGETHER. WE OFTEN SEE. JUST
THERE'S FIGHTS AYE GATHERINGS
THERE'S YOU KNOW SOMEONE DOES
ABOUT A HORSESHOE THEY GET MAD
AT EACH OTHER AND THEY'D GO
START GETTING INTO THIS WHOLE
DRAMA ABOUT THEIR FAMILY WE'RE
A DIVIDED COMMUNITY AND IT'S
THE TRUTH AND- AS MUCH AS I
LOVE MY CULTURE AND AS MUCH AS
I LEARN FROM IT IT'S NOT GOING
TO HOLD US ON TO FROM TOO MUCH
LONGER. AND I JUST REALLY WANT
TO. HAVE YOU GUYS REMEMBER THAT
THESE PROBLEMS WE HAD THERE NOT
JUST STORIES THAT WERE TELLING
YOU THERE ARE REAL LIFE
PROBLEMS AND THEY NEED TO BE
SOLVED ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
BECAUSE. WE'RE NOT NOTHING'S
HAPPENING WE'RE JUST GOING
DEEPER IN A HOLE THAT'S BEEN
DUG FOR US OVER. THOUSANDS OF
YEARS AND- IT'S REALLY NOT
GETTING ANY BETTER AND- YOU
KNOW ONE OF MY CLOSEST FRIENDS
SHE'S. MY CONSIDER HER AS A
REALLY CLOSE FAMILY MEMBER. BUT
SHE HAS ALL THESE DREAM SHE
TALKS ABOUT GOING TO COLLEGE
YOU KNOW SHE WANTS TO GO TO
BEAUTY SCHOOL SHOWS ALL THIS.
BUT SHE CAN'T EVEN GET A RIDE
TO HER OWN SCHOOL LET ALONE SHE
DOESN'T KNOW WHERE SHE'S GOING
TO SCHOOL THIS YEAR AND I'M
STARTING SCHOOL TOMORROW. AND
IT'S RELEASE SICKENING BECAUSE
SHE HAS TO PARENTS LIVING
WITHIN MINUTES OF EACH OTHER.
ON THE SAME RESERVATION BUT
NEITHER THEM HOW THEIR OWN
HOUSE THEY DON'T. HAVE A CAR
THEY CAN'T DRIVE HER TO SCHOOL
SO SHE'S OUT HERE YOU KNOW.
TRYING TO FIND RIGHTS TO SCHOOL
AND- YOU KNOW ONE OF MY COUSINS
THEY WON'T GIVE HER A RIDE TO
SCHOOL BECAUSE- THEY DON'T LIKE
HER BECAUSE OF SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED MAYBE IN FIFTH GRADE.
AND THEY'RE IN HIGH SCHOOL NOW.
AND IT'S REALLY SICKENING
BECAUSE- THESE KIDS ARE JUST
LOOKING FOR AN OPPORTUNITY
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR SOMETHING
THEY CAN HOLD ON TO. THEY WANT
OF. LIKE A LIGHT TO TURN ON AND
THEY WANT SOMETHING TO HAPPEN
BUT THE TRUTH IS NOTHING IS
HAPPENING. AND AS MUCH AS OUR
CULTURE MEANS SO MUCH TO US IN
AS MUCH AS IT YOU KNOW. IT'S
WHO WE ARE IT'S NOT SOLVING
ANYTHING REALLY AND. IT'S THESE
GANG MENTALITIES AND THESE YOU
KNOW LIFE OF HATRED THAT WERE
HOLDING ON TO BECAUSE THE TRUTH
IS THAT WE DON'T REALLY THERE'S
NOT MUCH AND I'M REALLY BLESSED
THAT I WAS GROWING UP IN A
COMMUNITY WHERE THEY ENCOURAGE
COLLEGE IN THE ENCOURAGE HIGHER
EDUCATION. BUT IT YOU CAN HAVE.
A TRIBE CAN HAVE A CASINO THEY
CAN HAVE ALL OF THAT BUT THE
TRUTH IS THAT THOSE GANG
MENTALITY STAY THERE AND THEY
INFLUENCE OUR KIDS AND OUR
PARENTS WERE INFLUENCE THE
EXACT SAME WAY. THEY'RE NOT AS
MUCH SUPPORT AS WE HAVE. SO I'M
KIND OF GOING ALL OVER THE
PLACE BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT IT'S THE OUR USES OUR
FUTURE LEADERS AND OUR USER AS
THEIR SO UNMOTIVATED BUT THE
TRUTH IS IT'S NOT JUST OUR
YOUTH THAT NEEDS HELP IT'S ARE
ADULTS THAT NEED HELP AND IT'S
OUR ELDERS THAT NEED HELP ALSO
WE WERE ALL CONFUSED AND WE'RE
ALL DIVIDED AMONGST EACH OTHER
AND OUR PARENTS BECAUSE HATE
BETWEEN EACH OTHER'S FAMILIES
AND WE GET INFLUENCED IF OUR
PARENTS SAY THEY DON'T LIKE
SOMEONE THE KIDS DON'T LIKE
SOMEONE IT'S NOT JUST THE USE
THAT WE SHOULD BE PAYING
ATTENTION TO ITS EVERYONE AND
WE NEED TO. HEAL OUR BROKEN
COMMUNITIES AND JUST AS. WE
NEED TO CALL ATTENTION AND
PUBLICITY IS A- THE REALLY THE
ONLY WAY TO GO FOR THIS
SITUATION BECAUSE. WE AREN'T
SEEN AS YOU KNOW OUR CULTURE IS
KIND OF OUR. I DON'T KNOW THIS
IS OUR GUESTS SCREENSAVER AND
AWAY THEY PEOPLE LOOK AT US YOU
WEAR FEATHERS AND YOU DO ALL
THIS STUFF BECAUSE I GO TO A
SCHOOL WHERE THERE'S ONLY ABOUT
SIX NATIVE SECOND OR SCHOOL AND
THERE'S ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
KIDS THAT GO THERE. AND YOU
KNOW I REMEMBER I HAD A MATH
ASSIGNMENT AND IT WAS OF COURSE
ABOUT IT WHAT DID THE NATIVE
CEDA SOME GUY OR WHATEVER AND
HE HAD A LIKE A BUCKET ON HIS
HEAD OR SOMETHING. BUT YOU KNOW
IT'S REALLY DISGUSTING SCENE
YOU KNOW JUST THOSE LITTLE
THINGS LIKE IT'S OKAY YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST WERE NOT
SEEN AS THE BROKEN COMMUNITIES
WERE SEEN AS- KIND OF CIRCUITS
TO LAUGH OUT OR WERE SEEN AS
YOU KNOW JUST FEATHERS AND WE
WRITE ON HORSES WHICH. COURSE
ISN'T REALLY FROM HERE ANYWAYS
SO. WHAT I'M TRYING TO SAY IS
THAT WE SHOULD REALLY
CONCENTRATE ON OUR YOUTH BUT
ONCE WORD FIGURING OUT A WAY TO
HELP THEM LET'S HELP THE REST
OF THE COMMUNITY AND HELP IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT AGE YOU ARE
THERE'S STILL AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR YOU NO MATTER WHAT AND I
THINK. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT. WE SIR ADDRESSING THESE
NOW BECAUSE- TO BE HONEST OUT
OF ALL MY COUSINS AND FRIENDS I
THINK THAT ME AND MY BROTHER
ARE THE ONLY ONES THAT. REALLY
WANT TO MAKE A CHANGE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THAT WILL STICK
TO OUR WORD. THANK YOU HE A HEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
TESTIMONY. UP IN BRINGING THE
SOME MUCH NEEDED DIALOGUE. TO
THE FOREFRONT HERE IN THE
SELECT COMMITTEE AND FROM THE
LEGISLATORS THAT ARE HERE. IS
THERE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THE
ONLY WOMAN GONZALEZ. HI MOM MOM
AND SO I JUST THOUGHT OF A LOT
OF KIDS YOU ARE SO WELL SPOKEN
AND YOU DID SUCH A GOOD JOB I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR
SHARING. YOUR STORY WITH US AND
REMINDING US I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU SAID AS YOU
KNOW TRY CAN HAVE A CASINO
DOESN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEMS
RIGHT. AND THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR
A LOT OF FOLKS TO UNDERSTAND.
HAVING FINANCIAL RESOURCES IS
BETTER THAN NOT HAVING THEM BUT
THERE ARE SO MANY DEEP ROOTED
ISSUES BECAUSE BY GENERATIONS
OF. OPPRESSION AND SYSTEMATIC
YOU KNOW MIGRATION AND
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED BUT YOU BRING A FRESH
PERSPECTIVE TO THAT AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU SPEAKING
TODAY. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
MEMBERS ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION FOR ALL THE
SPEAKERS IN THE PANELS THAT
WERE HERE AND TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO COME IN HERE THE
ISSUES THAT ARE FACING
CALIFORNIAN PEOPLE. IN THIS DAY
AND AGE AND GIVING US.
ULTIMATELY MARCHING ORDERS OF
WHAT CAN WE DO TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE ISSUES THAT ARE THERE
SONA THANK YOU AT THIS TIME I
WANT TO GO TO IF THERE'S ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. OUT THERE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE POLITICS READ ON
BEHALF OF BOTH THE CHIANG GAN
COLUSA TRIBES. REAL QUICKLY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN
RAMOSE FOR GOING TO THE SPEAKER
AND ASKING FOR THE COMMITTEE
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME AND
WAITING. FOR ALL THE MEMBERS
WHO WANTED TO JOIN THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR BEING
PART OF IT. AS YOU CAN SEE THAT
THE TRIBES HAVEL A LOT MORE
ISSUES THAN JUST GAMING WHICH
USUALLY HEAR A LOT OF THE
LOBBYISTS ON. I'M I WAS GOING
TO MAKE A COUPLE OF POINTS FOR
YOU TO THINK ABOUT AS A
COMMITTEE. OF ONE IS THE
SUPPORT OF NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION. I
REPRESENT A CHUNK OF FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. WHEN I FIRST
STARTED OUT. ARE THEY HAD AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BUT WE AS A
GROUP WENT TO THE THEN RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN AND
SAID YOU NEED TO HAVE A TRIBAL
ADVISER IN THE HORSESHOE. HE
DID THAT AND WE WORKED WITH THE
VERY FIRST ADVISER WERE WORKING
WITH THE SECOND ONE. THEY HAVE
A LOT ON YOUR PLATE AS YOU CAN
SEE. I REMEMBER THE FIRST
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION MEDIAN I WENT TO
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX YEARS
AGO. AND THEY HAD THREE STAFF.
AND THAT WAS CONSIDERED A BIG
STAFF AND THEY HAD TONS OF
THINGS TO DO. SO IS AS THIS
COMMITTEE PROGRESSES IT WOULD
BE GREAT IF YOU ALSO HELPED IN
THE BUDGET PROCESS TO MAKE
SURE. THEY HAVE MORE EMPLOYEES
NOW BUT THEY STILL HAVE A FULL
PLATE. AND CRISTINA SNYDER
CAN'T DO IT ALL ON HER OWN SHE
NEEDS HAVE A LOT OF BACK UP. IN
A LOT OF AREAS. COUPLE OF THEM
WHEN YOU'RE WELL AWARE OF. IS
AB FIFTY TWO WE FOUGHT OVER
SITE LEGISLATION A COUPLE OF
BILLS WENT THROUGH. INCLUDING
SB EIGHTEEN WITH STEINBERG. AND
THE PROBLEM IS THAT A LOT OF
LAWS AREN'T FOLLOW THAT ARE
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS MAYBE
FIFTY TWO IS ONE OF THEM. I
WOULD CAUTION ALL OF YOU AND
I'LL SEND A NOTE OUT TO THE
PRESS THE COMMITTEE. HOUSING
STREAMLINING. YOU GOT TO KEEP
IN MIND WE HAVE A BILL ON THE
BOOKS AB FIFTY TWO. IT'S ON
SAID SITES. NOTHING GIVES
STREAMLINING HOUSING BUT YOU
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
DON'T GIVE AWAY THOSE SACRED
SITES BY NOT LOOKING INTO EACH
OF THOSE BILLS HAVING. AB FIFTY
TWO LET WHICH AT THAT. AND
WE'RE. WORKING WITH SOME OF THE
AUTHORS AND ONE THAT. A NAG. UC
IS BEEN ATROCIOUS MY ALMA MATER
BERKELEY PHOEBE HEARST HAS
THOUSANDS OF BODIES IN BOXES
AND BAGS. THEY CRISTINA SNYDER
AND THE NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION ALONG WITH
LOWER MARANDA THE ACTING CHAIR
OF VARIETY OF CHAIRS OF TRIBES
HAVE MET WITH THE PALATINE IL
THEY PUT TOGETHER THIS ADVISORY
GROUP IT DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE
STILL GETTING REPATRIATION BACK
WERE MOVING THAT WAY. BUT AS AS
A ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA KNOWS
AND EVERYBODY WHO WORKED ON
THOSE BILLS THE UC'S ARE VERY
RELUCTANT TO GIVE UP THINGS
THEY THINK ARE THERE. AND I
GUARANTEE YOU IF IT WAS GRAHAM
A GARCIA OR OR GRAMMA RUBIO IN
A BOX IN A BAG IN THE BACK ROOM
YOU'D HAVE A BACK OF THE TRIBES
ARE NO DIFFERENT THEY DESERVE
TO HAVE THOSE REMAINS
REPATRIATED. VERSES. ZERO
CURATORS WHO CONSIDERED TO BE
THERE AROUND. AND IT IN
RELATION TO THE PAULA TANO THE
NEW CHAIR OF THE REGENTS A
PRESIDENT IS PREZ AND JOHN
PRESS IT'S BEEN A HUGE FAN. OF
EVERYTHING YOU'RE DOING AND THE
REPATRIATION. SO JUST A FEW
THINGS THAT ARE NON GAMING THAT
I HOPE THIS COMMITTEE WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT AND I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANY OTHER
PUBLIC PUBLIC COMING OUT THERE.
ONE OF MY THANK EVERYBODY FOR
ATTENDING THIS FIRST HISTORIC
SELECT COMMITTEE ON IT AMERICAN
AFFAIRS IN THIS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO. TOOK THE TIME TO
COMEIN HERE ABOUT THOSE ISSUES
THAT ARE THERE. I THANK
EVERYBODY AND TO THE EARLIER
PRESS CONFERENCE ANNOUNCING THE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR TRAVEL
DIVERSION PROGRAMS. IS MUCH
NEEDED AND WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD ADVOCATE. ON ALL
CALIFORNIA NEW PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR ATTENDING